[Musique]
christophe deloire bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinker view nous sommes
en direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
je suis né en bourgogne en saône et
loire j'ai vécu toujours aux confins de
la bourgogne et de l'auvergne dans un
petit village de du département de
l'allier et puis j'ai rêvé j'ai ensuite
j'ai fait un lapsus j'ai dit j'ai rêvé
oui j'ai beaucoup rêver quand j'étais
là-bas j'avais rêvé l'action regarder
l'horizon je regardais le ciel et puis
j'ai réalisé un rêve de gosse en fait je
suis devenu journaliste et la première
partie de ma carrière a consisté à
exercer directement le journalisme
essentiellement comme journaliste
d'investigation et j'ai enquêté sur
toutes sortes de choses sur les affaires
judiciaires
les erreurs judiciaires beaucoup les
services de renseignement le terrorisme
la capture oligarchique du pouvoir
l'influencé américaine et ses listes un
peu non
le terrorisme et notamment le terrorisme
islamiste mais aussi le terrorisme corse
je passais beaucoup de temps encore
j'ai fait ça dans la presse et dans
l'édition et puis une seconde partie
j'ai été directeur du centre de
formation des journalistes et
aujourd'hui depuis bientôt neuf ans je
suis à reporters sans frontières
l'organisation de défense de la liberté
de la presse et où notre combat c'est le
droit à l'information
l'information fiable indépendante et
pluraliste et quand on voit ce qui se
passe il ya de quoi être inquiet bon
avant qu'on commence à se taper et on
veut nous pesons va vraiment se taper
away accroché tiens toi tu es rotule
parce que ça va secouer très fort
aujourd'hui
je te lis ton presque autant que le
mandat
qu'on a on a décidé d'instituer cette
vidéo en route vers la dictature
vous nous avez suggéré en route vers la
guerre civile
c'est quoi votre perception du 21ème
siècle qui s'annonce on est en 2021
comment se comporte la france comment se
comporte le pouvoir français comment se
comporte la france à l'étranger
et puis on reviendra sur rsf un peu plus
tard
sur le sujet qui nous concerne parce que
la ja il ya douze questions dans la
question qui est tu viens me posez
moi j'ai une très grande inquiétude qui
est liée à nos droits à l'information au
pluralisme politique
a aujourd'hui c'est ces prédateurs de la
liberté de la presse qui sont d'un côté
donc les grands prédateurs qui sont les
régimes despotiques et notamment avec
quand même une
l'idée que face à la chine il va falloir
résister parce que la chine n est pas
simplement en train de contrôler sa
population elle al'intention elle a
entrepris de changer l'ordre mondial des
médias
il ya les plateformes numériques les
réseaux sociaux ces grandes sociétés de
la silicon valley ou l'équivalent des
gars femmes qui sont les beatrix en
chine y compris un pouvoir parce qu'on
leur a laissé mes compris à un pouvoir
démesuré
qu'est ce qui se passe dans les médias
avec d'un côté
une crise de la confiance
en fait le journalisme aujourd'hui les
victimes de beaucoup de crise la team de
lui-même nous dans les crises il peut y
avoir une crise morale et il est aussi
victime de lui-même et en fait il est
victime de facteurs externes et de
facteurs internes et on quand on a
publié récemment notre classe mondiale
de la liberté de la presse on a dit que
ça serait sans doute une décennie
décisive pour le journalisme parce qu'il
ya cinq crises qui se juxtaposent une
crise technologique ce que j'évoquais
avec les cas femme une crise économique
des médias une crise géopolitique
l'espèce de pouvoir que prennent les
régimes despotiques une crise
démocratique avec une polarisation de
société d'où l'idée de risque d'aller
vers une plus grande polarisation une
hystérisation plus grande et puis plus
de violence
une rupture de la concorde civile ça
c'est un risque on est déjà dans la
rupture après il peut y avoir des étapes
supplémentaires et puis enfin et c'est
peut-être une chose dont on parlera une
crise de la confiance vis-à-vis des
médias qu'à sa part de l'agît de
légitimité et que sa part
d'incompréhension
et donc on se retrouve et ça c'est
totalement nouveau dans l'histoire des
démocraties et pour moi c'est l'un des
plus grands facteurs de risques
aujourd'hui c'est le fait que pour la
première fois dans l'histoire des
démocraties ce qui édicte les normes de
la délibération publique ce qui règle la
manière dont on parle ce n'est plus les
parlements démocratiques
maintenant c'est mark zuckerberg ou
c'est le mark zuckerberg chinois et ça
c'est extrêmement dangereux
alors j'ai pas si on peut certes un
emploi l'expression de tyrannie privé on
en n'est pas exactement là mais en tout
cas notre espace public aujourd'hui il
est régi par une logique marchande
j'irai presse par une logique de
marchands de soupe et qui a une forme
d'intérêt à ce qui est
une virulence
une vindicte entre les gens parce que ça
marche plus
qui est des fausses informations qui
circulent qui est des propos de haine
qui est des rumeurs
en fait on se retrouve et ça c'est là
aussi nouveau dans une concurrence
directe entre des contenus qui n'ont
rien à voir c'est à dire la propagande
d'état la publicité le journalisme de
qualité le journaliste de moindre
qualité ça arrivait à coller la
propagande d'état
au pas seulement
la rumeur
la chanson sous la douche les insultes
d'un automobiliste à son volant
désormais tout ça se retrouve en
concurrence directe sur les réseaux
sociaux
et de ça nos démocraties peuvent je
crois que c'est pas un mot excessive
peuvent mourir donc on est à un moment
il faut se ressaisir il faut trouver des
solutions et moi je avec l'ensemble de
l'équipe de rsf on travaille à défendre
ce qui incarne les idéaux du journalisme
avec une vision exigeante du journalisme
c'est quoi c'est quoi cette vision là
bas c'est une vision que le journalisme
en fait il suffit pas de journalisme ça
ne pas s'exprimer tout le monde
s'exprime
ça n'est pas seulement être un
contre-pouvoir
contre-pouvoir les pleins pleins de
contre-pouvoir différents le journalisme
c'est
collecter traiter et diffuser des
informations en respectant des méthodes
et des règles éthiques
et c'est une partie de l'expression du
champ de l'expression une expression
particulière et qui a son utilité
sociale sa fonction sociale que moi je
qualifierais alors c'est un terme
emprunté à la finance où on dira au
notariat qui est d'être des des tiers de
confiance
ça veut dire que nous tous quand on
parle que ce soit en tant que citoyen en
tant qu'être humain en période de
pandémie inquiets pour notre survie où
notre santé en tant que qu'acteur
économique en tant qu tous acteurs
culturels etc
on est obligé de les léguer notre
confiance
d'autres ce sont là des legs on ne peut
pas tout à les voir tout savoir
la question qui se pose pour nos
sociétés c'est quelles sont les
conditions de la délégation de cette
confiance
est ce qu'on prétend et c'est l'utilité
sociale du journalisme et au delà de
toutes les critiques qui sont faites au
journalisme de crédito sont faites alors
juste part d'impôts pour terminer au
delà toutes les critiques qui sont
faites il ya une reconnaissance dans les
sondages de l'utilité du journalisme des
versions si on bat par exemple les
sociétés c'est à l'heure des craquements
ya pas soit n'y a pas très longtemps
dans les professions les plus respectés
à nos messages e genre de jeu c'est très
bien mais cette critique du journalisme
elle est toujours faite il ya un auteur
qui écrit là-dessus qui est françois
jost au nom d'une vision idéale du
journalisme en fait une passion du
journalisme un amour un amour voilà et y
compris chez ceux qui critiquent le
journalisme alors peut-être surtout
surtout surtout non parce qu'il ya aussi
des gens qui ne critique - can be found
critique plus
jean-michel aphatie c'est ça non alors
moi je suis totalement et
c'est vrai que de l'extérieur en
reporter sans frontières on peut avoir
l'impression d'être les gardiens du
temple clairement que nous ne sommes pas
enfin ça dépend de quel temple on parle
mais
il est évidemment les journalistes sont
pas infaillibles évidemment ils ont des
défauts mais l'utilité du journaliste le
fait qu'on ait besoin du journaliste
qu'au fond il ya un libéral américain
qui disait en 1920 c'est le moment où ça
tanguait walter lippmann la crise de la
démocratie occidentale est au sens
strict une crise du journalisme
en fait il ya vraiment une connexité
entre l'histoire de la démocratie telle
qu'on l'a conçu chez nous et le
journalisme pour résumer trivialement il
faut commencer à couper les têtes chez
les journalistes comme on a fait en
france
ça que si ces six une crise du jaunay
j'essaie de comprendre la question parce
que là je voulais être journaliste c'est
la question du genre et je voyais
reprendre confiance dans tout ça qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire il faut balayer d'un
revers de main tout ce qui a été fait il
faut changer les écoles de journalisme
comment on fait pour ré ont créé une
émulation dans la confiance faire table
rase et couper les têtes ça j'avais
servi à grand chose et généralement ça
finit par un régime plus dur soyons
clair donc ce qu'yves temps de savon se
retrouver avec le contraire de ce qu'ils
ont espéré
ce qu'il faut c'est créer les conditions
aujourd'hui
pour que et ça c'est un objectif
politique ça devrait être un objectif de
l'ensemble des partis politiques
qui est de créer les conditions pour que
les journalistes puissent travailler de
manière indépendante suis pas d'accord
puisse enquêter alors il faut aussi que
les gens n'aillent le fasse on y
reviendra mais il suffit pas d'être ça
sert à rien de juste dire faut qu'on y'a
qu'à y compris vous les journalistes
changé on peut le dire il ya plein de
gens qui disent ça suffit pas donc ce
qu'il faut cela me trouver des solutions
les évolutions sociales elles se font
quand on trouve des idées et les idées
c'est elles sont aussi liées aux règles
du jeu à l'organisation du marché à
toutes sortes de choses il faut rentrer
et je crois que c'est une chose qu'on
fait ici dans les aspects systémiques
dont dans l'organisation du système donc
pour changer les choses ça commence par
déjà un bon gros mea culpa un ancien si
la presse devait se faire par
l'intermédiaire de votre voix devait
faire son mea culpa ça commencerait par
quoi
je me permets de commenter la question
je pense que non mais là je pense que
c'est important a dit on verra on peut
faire toute la question on peut faire
des critiques journalistes qu'on va je
vais
mais livrer parce que j'ai beaucoup de
choses à dire aussi là dessus
mais dire d'abord
qu'il faut les critiques absolu total
toutes les nuls tout et sont aberrantes
m'ont pas commencer par un gentil merck
volera mois lorsque ce que je perçois
c'est que sur les facteurs internes qui
justifie la critique du journalisme
les journalistes trop souvent se
comportent en cléricature moral
et ça les gens ne le supporte pas c'est
à dire les journalistes ne sont pas plus
intelligents que les autres même quand
ils sont très intelligents fonds publics
doivent pas le
considérer
parce que leur jugement sur les choses
il est nécessairement biaisé par les
catégories sociales auxquelles ils
appartiennent celle qu'ils rencontrent
leurs origines et état
et qui a des phénomènes sociologiques
et que les journalistes sans quoi ils
sont utiles c'est d'aller chercher de
l'information
de la rapporter fidèlement
de l'analyse et honnêtement et j'en ai
assez des règles d'honnêteté normalement
les ontologies de déontologie ouais mais
j'appelle rec 2 n'était pas ce que le
mot déontologie peut être obscur mais au
fond c'est un dominique va quand même
c'est quoi la charte de munich s'est dit
devoir 5 droit plus de devoirs que de
droits humains censés c'est bien à bannu
et la charte de munich elle est dans nos
statuts à reporters sans frontières
c'est la charte de la fédération
européenne des journalistes
qui a été adoptée en 1971 signé par l'ex
union soviétique
signé alors pas par l'union c'est une
charte de syndicat sypol une charte pays
des syndicats qui l'ont signé et qui a
été inspiré par la première charte en
france a été la charte des journalistes
du syndicat national des journalistes de
et qui arrive c'est pas un hasard à la
fin de la première guerre mondiale et
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose qui est
un peu remarquable dans l'histoire et où
il faudrait inverser la logique c'est
que généralement la déontologie elle
arrive après les conflits
si on regarde la construction du
journalisme il ya d'abord les guerres du
19e siècle la guerre de sécession la
guerre de crimée où pour la faune de
première fois il ya du reportage un peu
j'allais dire tel compte fait
aujourd'hui et c'est après ces conflits
que sont créé la première école de
journalisme dans le missouri aux états
unis à la fin du 19e au tout début du
xxème que la society of professional
journalistes aux états unis il dicte une
charte déontologique est remarquable
puis le cng pu être et puis les droits
de l'homme qui eux surviennent après le
second conflit mondial
pourquoi parce que la perception du
besoin déontologique du besoin de
responsabilité dans la discussion
publique d'ailleurs quand on regarde des
droits de l'homme le seul droit le droit
dans lequel il ya le plus le mot
responsabilité dans le pacte relatif aux
droits civils et politiques et le texte
juridique d'interprétation de la
déclaration universelle de droits comme
c'est la liberté d'expression c'est
parce que précisément s'il n'y a pas des
formes de responsabilité alors on peut
aller vers la violence verbale qui peut
amener à la guerre ou au conflit et
d'ailleurs les journalistes les
journalistes ont largement contribué au
premier conflit mondial qu'est ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut rajouter à cette
longue liste de mea culpa que la
profession devrait faire pour regagner
la confiance auprès de son public
je passais la culpabilité qui sert à
quelque chose la question c'est de de
remédier à ce qui vous sentez toile un
peu
non mais coupable moi je vois des
projets des problèmes des choses qui
doivent être améliorés
et je me bats pour que ça soit le cas et
je me bats avec une équipe
défaut d'indépendance ça c'est une chose
qui est beaucoup reproché aux
journalistes
on y reviendra peut-être la question
notamment des oligarques qui possèdent
des médias en france ong
des médias qui possèdent des ong qui
précède et ong
pas très bien que vous faites allusion
mais bon y'a peut-être tout à l'heure
donc les défauts d'indépendance tous les
phénomènes je dirais de corruption
journalistique du conflit d'intérêts ça
il ya une forme il ya une telle attente
du journalisme
une attente légitime que les
journalistes ne soient pas dans des
situations de conflit d'intérêts c'est
quoi une situation confie aujourd'hui
c'est quoi ce alors moi je suis sûr
c'est que c'est quoi c'est le ménage cc
on va faire un petit peu de ménage chez
un milliardaire aux ménages c'est quoi
c'est animé animer une petite tombola
animer un petit carnet ce1 sais quoi
d'autre cc recevoir une commande pour
faire un papier pour discréditer
l'adversaire politique c'est quoi ça
c'est sans les commandes moi je crois
qu'il y en ait pas j'ai une certaine
expérience sage jeu des papiers de
commandes depuis que dire ça peut
arriver mais suggérer un nom mais de la
commande la commande au sens rémunérées
non alors c'est les ménages est ce qu'on
appelle les ménages c'est le fait de
faire des prestations hors exercice
professionnel mais qui évidemment
peuvent avoir une forme d'incidence pour
des entreprises par exemple
je suis journaliste à tel endroit sur
une radio et je vais travailler pour
coca cola le week-end
ça malheureusement ça existe pas qu pour
cook et kaunas est un exemple oui c'est
un exemple
c'est
d'autres modes de moi ce que je
considère des formes de corruption alors
certains trouveront peut-être
radicale mais je pense qu'il faut l'être
en la matière qui est des voyages de
presse les invitations
on vous invite au bout du monde
pour un
voire le lancement de tels produits
parce que franchement il faut vraiment
aller sur une île paradisiaque faire un
petit speech
alors ça c'est le faire le petit speech
ac plutôt situation initiale ça c'est le
ménage donc le ménage le voyage de
presse alors c'est pas comme c'est pas
le même type dans d'autres sur d'autres
continents en chine par exemple
on met parfois des enveloppes sur les
chaises dans les conférences de presse
pour que les journalistes viennent à la
conférence de presse
dans certains pays africains il ya des
formes de corruption très très visible
chez nous elles sont moins être sont
moins vie mais elle existe je ne
voudrais pas chacun chacun de vos
auditeurs pense que c'est systématique
ou même que c'est généralisé mais ça
existe ça existe de manière importante
trop importante et ça si on veut
retrouver la confiance du public faut
qu'on leur montre qu'on n'est pas en
train de défendre des intérêts
chaque journaliste chaque média peut
avoir une ligne éditoriale et même la
neutralité ça n'existe pas c'est une
aberration la neutralité l'objectivité
au sens strict ça n'existe pas ce qui
existe
c'est ce que hubert beuve méry fondateur
du monde appelait une subjectivité
désintéresser des intéressés c'est à
dire on a coupé les relations d'intérêts
on a prohibé les conflits d'intérêts et
ça il doit y avoir des mesures
extrêmement strictes et de ce point de
vue là il ya même
un self considère qu'il faut mettre en
place des mesures qui sont plus
radicales pour éviter ce genre de
phénomène qui se passe aussi parce que
alors honnêtement il ya des journalistes
parfois très bien rémunéré qu'ils font
c'est complètement je dirais du métier
c'est pas très bien rémunéré très bien
rémunéré par rapport à des journalistes
ray mais ce que je peux dire c'est le
niveau de rémunération des journalistes
d'après les chiffres de la commission de
la carte de presse en moyenne
les journalistes en cdi en france touche
3500 euros plus les niches fiscales
l'avantagé fiscal que c'est pas une
niche exactement mais un avantage fiscal
une remise à tva qui veut de metz une
réduction du revenu imposable de 7650
euros il touche christophe deloire sur
sa fiche de pays moi je touche
5000 ou 5500 euros par mois net avant
impôt sur le revenu est une petite niche
fiscale aussi de 5000 7600 ça c'est la
réduction d'impôt imposable aussi oui
moi je peux dire
je crois que c'est le gouvernement
jospin si je me souviens bien qu'il a
eue de l'enlever à les voies où je
travaillais
pigiste notamment pour arte je n'ai il y
avait grève pour protester contre la
réduction moi j'ai pas fais quand même
moi je veux pas trés trés à titre
personnel je pas favorable à l'existence
de cette réduction qui a pu avoir un
sens il a un moment dans l'histoire que
l'on n'a plus nécessairement aujourd'hui
cela dit bon nombre des journalistes
ça représente pas grand chose pour eux
parce qu'il ya aussi j'ai cité là le la
moyenne pour les journalistes en cdi
pour les pigistes et 2000 euros
et aujourd'hui à 35 mille journalistes
en france
ce nombre est à peu de ce alors il c'est
une légère réduction là sur une période
longue mais la réduction en et légère
que parce qu'en fait les barèmes ont
changé mais que les critères ont changé
qu'il ya quelques années encore il
fallait toucher pour être reconnu comme
journaliste en fait sur trois mois de
manière lycée au moins le smic et que
désormais c'est la moitié du smic donc
il ya comme une forme de précarisation
de la profession qui est extrêmement
inquiétante on continue mea culpa donc
ça
mais d'autres alma culpa
le défaut d'indépendance la cléricature
moral ça je pense que c'est vraiment une
chose moi je me souviens quand j'étais
directeur du centre de formation des
journalistes j'avais invité enfin
j'invite à et des responsables
politiques de toutes parts j'avais
arrêté jean luc mélenchon qui avait fait
un discours assez remarquable sur la
question bon après sur les journalistes
il a tenu des propos qui étaient moins
remarquable quand il a parlé de deux n
saine et juste mais mais là dessus c'est
un sujet c'est à dire les gens ont trop
l'impression que les médias veulent les
influencer
de manière inconsciente il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de complot des médias il
n'ya pas d'uniformité il ya quand même
des médias qui défendit éditorial
différentes il ya des tabous et moi je
pense qu'il ya dans les tabous il y en a
un
qui est très fort qui est économique et
qui a beaucoup joué c'est la question du
protectionnisme
c'est à dire pendant très longtemps
c'est un peu moins le cas ça c'est même
moins le cas mais
les peuples et notamment en europe et
est protectionniste
et ça ne paraissait pas dans les
journaux je ne suis pas en train de dire
que le protectionnisme est
nécessairement une bonne idée
mais cette demande populaire forte elle
n'était pas représenté dans librement et
ça c'était une forme de
c'était évidemment un problème alors qui
s'est traduit d'ailleurs d'une autre
manière au moment du traité
constitutionnel européen enfin du
référendum sur le traité constitutionnel
européen ou
disons le tout les médias étaient en
faveur du oui
comme avec macro non
jeu tous les médias étaient en faveur du
oui sauf marianne qui disait c'est
scandaleux tout le monde était en faveur
du oui était quand même en faveur du oui
donc là il ya eu je pense une rupture de
la confiance à ce moment là c'était de
dire il ya quand même une partie des
aspirations populaires qui ne sont pas
représentés
voilà ça je pense qu'il faut le dire il
faut le reconnaître il faut pas savoir
le reconnaître il faut le traiter et
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est ces deux
d'avoir un pluralisme large
dans les médias moi je récuse l'idée
selon laquelle les journalistes sont des
petits soldats des oligarques qui
possèdent des médias eux
je ne suis pas en train de dire que ça
n'a pas d'influencé à de l' influence
mais ce sont mes sur non mais y'a pas
l'auto censure ça existe malheureusement
c'est toujours très difficilement
mesurables et c'est toujours ce qu'on
prête à l'autre dans tous les sens voyez
non à cette thématique c'est beau et ça
vous partout dans le monde comment
mesure l'autocensure comment l'évaluer
c'est toujours comme très subjectif mais
mais qu'en tout cas y est
mais il ya une chose qui se produit et
ça moi je je je peux constater c'est que
le journal c'est quand même un métier de
désir il ya
beaucoup de gens qui aspirent à faire du
journalisme il y en a moins qui
réussissent et donc il ya un effet
sociologique qui fait qu'à un moment il
ya une forme de reproductions
deuxième est une reproduction qui est
lié à
à ce haut fait que certains peuvent
avoir le sentiment que pour être élu il
faut
il faut adhérer un corpus d'idées
surtout quand c'est dans son école de
journalisme non
alors ça c'est sans doute une allusion
au fait que j'en ai dirigé une que j'ai
dirigées de crj moi j'ai dirigé pendant
quatre ans moi j'ai pas fait d'école de
journalisme à titre personnel et je dois
même dire ça demain et je je m'interroge
pourquoi ça n'est jamais venu à l'esprit
je sais pas pourquoi bon j'en ai dirigé
une sur le tard
je pense que c'est utile les écoles du
genre les écoles du genre est ce qu on
leur met beaucoup sur le dos alors
qu'elle non formés que 15 à 20% des
journalistes
mais je dois dire moi j'ai chaque année
je dirigeais fâche présidait 150
entretiens parce qu'il y avait des
écrits puis avait d euros et
j'essayais sur une obsession mais
j'avais une obsession c'était de de ne
pas faire les petits soldats du
journalisme
c'est le bouquin de rufin quand j'arrive
au clj le bouquin que j'avais sous le
bras le jour où je suis arrivé c'était
le bouquin de rouen
je ne suis pas d'accord avec tout dans
ce bouquin mais il y avait quelque chose
et donc il y avait des enjeux qui était
la diversité sociale
ça on a beaucoup fait progresser
la diversité intellectuelle
je ne vais pas parler que de succès donc
je ne suis pas juste en train de vendre
sa camelote mais la diversité sociale en
modifiant les concours en mettant des
dispositifs dead en favorisant
l'apprentissage ça marche
mais il la diversité sociale ne veut pas
dire la diversité intellectuelle et ne
veut pas dire le pluralisme après
deux
la diversité intellectuelle ça c'est un
problème c'est que c'est très difficile
c'est que les gens qui viennent au
journalisme
spontanément en france sont plutôt des
gens qu'on fait histoire sciences po et
lettres
moi je voulais des matins
je veux des gens qu'on fait de la techno
ça c'est pas gentil avec mon autre
je voulais des des gens qui
confie médecine
et je dis pas ça aujourd'hui à cause du
colis c'était le cas à l'époque et ça
c'est très dur en fait ce qui viennent
pas
et le troisième sujet c'est donc la
question du pluralisme après et ça
vous apercevez que le donc ce deuxième
point c'était plutôt un échec je te le
dire et le troisième sujet qui est est
ce que la diversité sociale est-ce que
s'il suffit diversifier les visages on
peut considérer qu'il a une importance à
diversifier le visage mais ça ne suffit
pas à
diversifier l'offre éditoriale
après à la fin
qu'on considère que j'ai fait un mea
culpa ou pas moi je n'ai pas présenté
comme un mea culpa c'est pas assez on
peut continuer mais je peux quand même
glissé à un moment
que
je vois beaucoup de journalistes qui
franchement ils vont comme dans
l'article premier de la charte de munich
chercher la vérité alors c'est pas donc
non pas quoi qu'il en coûte comme dit à
maquereau mais quelles qu'en soient les
conséquences pour soi même ça c'est
beaucoup me fera du même nom
et ne pas servir ses propres ni ne pas
servir ses propres intérêts par exemple
j'ai fait le journal ça n'est pas
toujours facile en essayant et je dis
pas qu'on y parvient toujours mais de
m'affranchir de mes propres du préjugé
d'essayer de trouver je pense qu'il est
bon genre nice qui font ça enfin jeu
franchement pas une exception
d'essayer de trouver une forme de
liberté pensées intérieures pour pouvoir
aller regarder le monde s'en aller faire
le tri avant et puis regardez on a fait
le tri voilà
et parce qu'il ya un enjeu majeur
aujourd'hui qui est le rapport entre les
questions de vérité les questions de
réalité vous c'est pas du tout la même
chose
je pense que c'est l'une des grandes
incompréhensions y compris sur ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis où
on comprend pas alors il ya plein de
fous furieux évidemment dans ceux qui
sont allés au capitole et dans il ya des
fous furieux dans ce qu'on vaut d'être
up y a pas que ça
et il ya une chose qu'il faut quand même
arriver à comprendre c'est pourquoi des
gens préfèrent et trouve qu'il ya plus
de vérité dans les mensonges de donald
trump
ou de piano enfin
on est encore sur un terrain à un autre
terrain mais dans les mensonges de
donald trump que par exemple dans les
médias américains
mais je crois qu'il faut avoir toujours
à l'esprit que on doit chercher la
vérité on doit rencontre de la réalité
et la vérité c'est allé vérifier la
véracité d'un fait est ce que c'est vrai
ou pas alors c'est jamais la vérité avec
un grand v mais ça ça a du sens de
chercher là
la véracité d'un fait et je rapproche un
ca d'une certaine manière la démarche
journalistique de la démarche
scientifique c'est la fameuse théorie de
popper sûr qu est ce qu un fait
scientifique
c'est un fait irréfutable sur le
principe qui n'a pas encore été réfutées
c'est à dire jusqu'à démonstration que
c'était
la même chose pour journalistes oranje
la réalité c'est une diversité de fait
une pluralité de fait et on peut aller
chercher des faits qui sont tous vrai
mais avec un regard biaisé et certains
disent les attend il y en a tout il ya
d'autres choses dont vous parlez pas
pourquoi vous n'en parlez pas donc c'est
un mensonge ou vérité
et je peux en train de justifier tout
l'héritage du populisme en disant ça
mais on doit s'interroger là-dessus et
il s'agit pas simplement d'aller servir
aux gens ce qu'ils veulent entendre
même si de plus en plus et notamment du
fait de l'organisation du marché chacun
peut entendre simplement ce qu'ils ont
envie d'entendre
et ça sert si ça c'est un réseau in&fi à
la fin parce que c'est assez c'est
totalement destructeur de la concorde
sociale c'est à dire
il y à dents dans la sociologie du
journal il ya deux types de journal s'il
ya le genre de rassemblement qui vise à
nous essayer d'asseoir une forme de
commun et puis un jour est de
décentrement que plus tôt je me déporte
je regarde de loin le système et je le
critique
les deux femmes sont légitimes on a
besoin des deux
mais donc l'organisation aujourd'hui
elle fait que malheureusement
on peut simplement aller chercher chacun
la chaîne qui simplement nous confortera
dans nos opinions et nous en fermera
encore un peu plus dans la bulle
filtrante ça on est passé un truc sur
lequel il doit prendre ce type de chaîne
c'est un que nous on essaie d'écouter à
peu près tout le monde au grand dam de
certains qui voudraient mettre dans des
cases ou qui voudraient nous imposer
leur pureté idéologique et on en a fini
et que le mea culpa ou continuer un
petit peu en fait c'est le petit mea
culpa le titre de l'émission mais
c'était énorme et un jeu mais on a
changé
très bien le
sae jeu mais lee volontiers on peut
continuer plein de sujets en revanche si
ça amène à penser que
les médias les médias d'information je
parle pas des médias de divertissement
il dira divertissement mais en fait
médias au sens strict ces intermédiaires
et donc non c'est simplement ce qu'ils
diffusent delà de la musique enfin
divertissement ou artistes ou artistique
du cinéma de média veut pas dire
information enfin - formation veut dire
beaucoup de choses différentes en fait
c'est vraiment un mot polysémique mais
de l'information au sens de
l'information journalistique
et
qui était la question pardon mea culpa
oui
c'est dur sûrement non c'est toujours
l'impression que je n'avais pas été
suivi ça reste gentil là c'est très
policé quand même
la différence entre mark ii
on est dans une situation qui est
aujourd'hui très très très ennuyeuse
enfin qui est même dangereuse que pas
seulement nui yeux
pour
en fait on peut être manipulé tout part
parce que jusqu'à présent alors pour
essayer de parler du champ de
l'information en général
l'histoire des démocraties elle a
constitué a essayé de poser des formes
de responsabilité sur les intermédiaires
parce qu'en fait le débat public était
il y avait un intermédiaire qui étaient
les médias d'information
sauf qu'en avec le rtf le président
s'exprimait de lui-même mais en gros il
ya toujours des intermédiaires et donc
le responsable politique le patron
d'entreprise le syndicaliste le
belligérant dans une guerre ou témoins
quand il s'exprimait
il y avait un intermédiaire qui était
journaliste et qui rapportait ensuite
l'information
et donc
comme ça c'est vrai
ça part mal
la réalité technologique la réalité de
cette organisation à un moment c'est pas
nécessairement un choix est donc ce qui
a été entrepris c'est plus ou moins bien
deux c'est de poser des droits et des
obligations sur ses intermédiaires
alors ce on pourra voir le verre à
moitié vide ou le verre à moitié plein
qu'à ceux qui diront oui
et je pense que c'est incontestable ya
une professionnalisation de journalisme
où il ya des règles éthiques
et la majorité des journalistes la
majorité des journalistes les respecte
je sais pas si je vais dans le sens de
de la majorité de l'audience city s'il
ya au queen's non jamais je parlais de
l'audience n'avait pas au niveau de
l'audience ouais je sais qu'elle est
très hétéroclite où diverses
donc
respect des règles éthiques scrupules
sur la vérification
et tenté au cours de l'histoire et y
compris de l'histoire récente en france
puisqu'une loi alors que malheureusement
très insatisfaisante et cas pas beaucoup
d'effet sur l'indépendance en 2016 la
loi dite bloch sur l'indépendance de
l'information
et pour essayer de poser des garanties
sur l'indépendance et puis évidemment il
ya eu plein de tentatives pour dominer
l'information parce qu'à la fin la
formation c'est un peu ça peut pouvoir
en fait
c'est tout le pouvoir non mes pouvoirs
de chacun et et des journées c'est à
dire
alors pouvoir des journalistes les
journalistes n'ont pas d'agenda
iata 4ème place tout journaliste et que
moi j'avais passé un vrai dire pas de 15
ce jour ne l'a jamais il n'y a pas de
casque je n'ai pas fini ma phrase c'est
pour ça y'a pas de caste journalistique
qui veut qu'à son agenda pour le monde
et pour la france n'était pas content
non mais c'est un milieu qui comme tous
les milieux mais traversée d' influence
reichel ferron générale 1 to et un clou
et
abaya des métiers qui sont plus normé là
on est dans le champ de la liberté
d'expression plus ou moins les normes ce
et les règles les méthodes
professionnelles
vérification contradictoires
si j'écris quelque chose sur vous je
vous appelle avant
je
travaille sur la base de documents et
pas simplement au d'imputation fait par
n'importe qui
vous mettez pas sous le robinet du de
l'information du ministère de
l'intérieur ou en attendant que ça
ministère de l'intérieur ni de personne
ça s'est souvent encore celle des
journalistes qui attendent de se faire
un peu douché
mais qu'il puisse y avoir chez les
journalistes comme chez d'autres des
forme de paresse oui évidemment
mais aussi plein de gens courageux et
oui au moment là où on parle de la
confiance je me souviens quand deux
journalistes vérifient ce sont fait tuer
au mali franchement faut faut imaginer
ce que c'est quand on est journaliste
vous êtes dans votre domicile vous
faites votre valise et vous allez au
mali en guerre et là vous faites buté
est bien là vous avez des gens ayant lu
énormément à ce moment là qu'ils
viennent dire que vous y alliez pour
l'argent pour la célébrité et sait
banon y sont allés pour parce qu'il
croit un idéal et ça c'est qu'ils font
aussi pour le pognon
non mais il sait aussi gagner leur vie
mais
c'est très intéressant ça quand même il
faut arriver on peut voir je disais le
verre à moitié vide ou à moitié plein
mais c'est une erreur de noix et
et c'est très légitime et c'est très
exigeant de parler du côté à moitié vide
mais c'est très injuste et je pense
quand même très dangereux de ne pas voir
le côté à moitié plein nous suivons
pourquoi pourquoi c'est dangereux parce
que je voudrais quand même le dire parce
qu'au fond parfois est alors quand vous
faites l'excellence journalistique quand
vous faites une enquête un article c'est
ça c'est que les gens de gauche ils vous
disent ton truc qu'il est vraiment super
à droite c'est scandaleux les gens de
droite ils vous disent à ton truc qui
est super à gauche et scandaleux enfin
vous êtes critiqué dans tous les sens et
les gens jugent en fait - le travail
journalistique ou même un mec qui
allaient à bagdad et ils disent c'est
n'importe quoi ça se passe pas comme ça
à bagdad mais vas-y à bagdad voir et
donc la finition n'est pas que iad et
qu'on voit que le journaliste qui à
bagdad en fait s'il fait son reportage
dans les chiottes
non mais
on raconte qu'il ya eu des ça fait
partie des blagues certains reporters de
guerre qui le faisait depuis la cabine
téléphonique de la place de la bourse à
paris c'est la blague
très peu d'exemples mais les reporters
de guerre ils sont essentiellement sur
le terrain ils sont pas dans la cabine
téléphonique qui n'existe plus place de
la bourse à paris comme ceux qui font
des interview de fidel castro mais sans
fidel castro ou non oui bob allusion à
ppda
de l'interview reconstituer qu a fait un
mal terrible
la pierre qui était par ailleurs jeunes
et où je suis pas du tout coquine a vécu
mais qu'il était un type comme moi je
les fais parce que j'ai début j'ai
travaillé là tf1 et franchement il
savait tout sur tout j'étais
impressionné par sa culture et sa ce
genre d'affaires ça fait un
peu comme les charniers de timisoara
n'ont donc pardon je voudrais quand même
sacrément mon histoire des deux verres
d'eau et pas simplement ah oui et puis
je montre mon verre parce que j'ai un
verre ici du verre plein à moitié plein
si on voit pas ça en fait on se retrouve
parfois on le fait ou des gens
extrêmement pure subjectivité
et font la critique des médias alors que
encore aujourd'hui dans le champ de
l'information si on met tous
les propos balancé sans la moindre
vérification
la propagande dans deux
d'entreprise de groupes religieux de
tout ça ça a une valeur quand même et
donc je récuse totalement l'idée selon
laquelle il faut tout détruire parce qu
on détruirait quelque chose qui a de la
valeur la question c'est de corriger ses
défauts est ce que c'est encore nous
c'est encore faisable
l'inertie que cette je vais utiliser le
bon mot que cette caste a pu prendre
pendant des décennies est-ce que avec
l'accélération de l'histoire
l'accélération du temps économiques
l'accélération du temps épidémique même
est-ce que c'est pas trop tard pour
faire un petit peu son mea culpa changer
le changer des choses faire pénitence
mais il est ensuite est-ce que c'est pas
trop tard est-ce que c'est pas un peu
encore du wishful thinking deux
journalistes en disant oui on va se
réformer vous comprenez on a bien
identifié
pourquoi il y avait des fêtes news on
sait tout ça on sait que les quatre il y
en a que quatre qui font des ménages
tout va bien madame la marquise tout ira
bien moi ce que je vois c'est une
société où il ya des distances des
dissensions qui sont plus fortes que
jamais une profession qui est aussi
respectée que les croque morts et et on
continue à avoir des journalistes oui
mais vous comprenez il faut pas voir le
verre à moitié plein le verre à moitié
vide on essaye quand même on essaye le
résultat de l'histoire c'est vous ouvrez
la porte vous prenez n'importe quel
pékin dans la rue ou dit alors
journaliste est bien est il donc je
pense dans 90% du temps ça se fait
secouer très fort mais
là on peut on peut être fasciné par la
la la la destruction non mais moi ce
matin c'est la construction est d'accord
on n'est pas fasciné par la destruction
ni par la construction quoi que ce soit
on fait simplement un constat froid que
votre profession et on l'a crédité pour
israël et pour la faire changer pour la
bousculer un peu là j'en ai encore sur
internet qui me dirige jusqu'à y
bouscule le
comme ils sont assis son nourrisson
protéger tout va bien ils ont la pureté
idéologique tout se passe bien et vous
croyez que c'est pas trop quand ils sont
tous protégés etc je suis désolé il
déguste en plus des mauvais sens du
terme oui bien sûr
ils en prennent plein la gueule
quand ils couvrent des manifestations
pendentifs en détenant mais quand ils
font des enquêtes quand ils
les jeunes générations de journalistes
qui sont
plus précarisés encore
dont certains s'efforcent de trouver de
nouveaux modèles économiques mais aussi
rédactionnelle enfin le journalisme est
aussi en ré invention
on peut être là cinglant faites tout
votre mea culpa alignés
et tout ira mieux non ça ira mieux si on
reconstruit et et si on évite une
destruction plus grande encore et la
grande destruction et c'est pas ce dont
on a parlé plus là aujourd'hui c'est les
plateformes numériques c'est les
sociétés de la civic on y vient on y
vient on lire donc revenons vous à vous
avez vous avez amené sur la table un
sujet qui est intéressant c'est les
journalistes dans les manifs
on va élargir un peu le sujet on va dire
aussi les journalistes en théâtre
d'opération
un premier cas de figure et gilet jaune
est ce que ce mouvement social ce
printemps français a été couvert
correctement par votre caste
le lob mais rate le temps georges
connaissez le réflexe de lawrence
assez le fait de regarder un service sa
salive j'aime voir mon verre d'eau c'est
pour ça et puis je prends le temps de
réfléchir parce que c'est une question
importante
le problème du journaliste c'est dépassé
les événements
qu'ils étaient là qu'est ce que
ben je sais ce qu'on a découvert les
filets jaunes
parce qu'il ya plusieurs les gilet jaune
fait plusieurs choses
c'est des événements je porte dans les
rues de paris disons ou des autres en
ville
c'est aussi la situe la signification
politique de ce mouvement les causes de
ce mouvement ce qui se passe
dans le rond point sur le rond-point des
petites villes mais aussi dans la maison
qui fait que quelqu'un à bord et l'enjeu
pour les journalistes c'est d'arriver à
ce que l'événement qui est parfois plus
fascinants puisque l'événement
généralement c'est un accident c'est des
phrases cas ça peut être des violences à
l'arc de triomphe
qu'il fallait évidemment montré
mais on est tous
plus fasciné par des images chocs
et donc
sur les chaînes tout info lima les
images chocs et d'ailleurs j'observe et
je suis pas en train de défendre bfm tv
mais que les gens qu'on critique et bfm
tv il y en avait des deux côtés il ya
des gens qui disaient c'est scandaleux
vous servez la soupe au gilet jaune
à force de les montrer comme ça toute la
journée
vous les encourager et puis avait ce
qu'ils aient
sur les mêmes images exactement le
contraire c'est à dire c'est dégueulasse
vos images sont contre le mouvement
était donc on se retrouve comme dans
situations où ou tout le monde critique
en fait
franchement la critique c'est le truc il
faut la défendre ça fait partie de la
charte de munich c'est même un rôle des
journalistes de défendre le droit à la
critique mais mais ça fait pas est-ce
qu'ils ont bien couvert r
moi je suis allé alors je peux aller à
toutes les manifestations je suis allé
voir à quoi ça ressemblait et et c'est
toujours intéressant de voir et moi j'ai
vu
j'ai vu la france
j'ai vu enfin j'ai vu plein de choses et
le la difficulté des gilet jaune pour
tout le monde je crois c'est que c'était
quand même très difficile à comprendre
ou bien le dire parce que il y avait des
gens très différents mais moi quand j'y
suis allé et moi je suis allé sur les
champs elysées à paris angers pas
d'ailleurs je suis allé là j'ai vu ceux
à qui je parlais c'était des gens de
l'yonne
de voile à 100 200 km de paris qui était
livreur qui était dans les supermarchés
qui faisait valoir une forme de
ras-le-bol et et cette france-là
cette france périphérique
cette france qui fait vivre le pays
ouais enfin tout le monde s'est vu enfin
tout le monde fait vu le pays à part les
centre-villes font aussi vivre le pays
il n'ya pas qu'eux mais cette france qui
est nombreuse
cette france des petites villes ça on a
coutume de dire que 80% de la population
française vit en ville en réalité
40 à 50% des gens vivent dans des
petites villes parce que les
statistiques de l'insee cd ville de 2000
habitants quand vous vivez dans une
ville de 10 15 milles habitants dans un
raid département rural
vous êtes dans la ruralité vous n'êtes
pas dans le coeur des centres villes
porté à la mondialisation et enfin voilà
donc il ya des des contradictions très
forte de la société
avec des intérêts divergents et c'est
normal dans les démocraties et les
journalistes jeu sans doute ont parfois
du mal à rendre compte suffisamment de
ces de ses intérêts divergents de la
légitimité de ses intérêts divergents et
donc peut-être que le la difficulté
traitement ou de mauvais traitements il
en amont plus que sur la manifestation
elle-même
donc ça a été traité comme ça a été
traitée page vient de répondre j'ai pas
dis que ça a été commence alors une
autre question reviendra sur les
manifestations et la couverture des
journalistes en manifestations et sur le
territoire notre territoire français moi
j'ai une question qui est un peu plus
large comment ça se fait maintenant que
sur les théâtres de guerre c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour un reporter
d'éviter de se faire catégorisé comme
agent de renseignement élément
perturbateur éléments de renseignement
sous couverture de journalistes ou c'est
pareil pour des ong pourquoi les ong les
journalistes maintenant ce fonds dégagés
par tous les belligérants de des zones
de conflit
alors certains diront que c'est les
conflits qu'on évolue et qu'il ya moins
de lignes de front au clair et donc
c'est plus difficile de s'y repérer moi
je crois qu une raison simple et qu'elle
y est en fait à l'évolution
technologique
et qui revient à ce que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure sur la question des
intermédiaires c'est qu'avant et j'ai
cité les belligérants comme les
politiques comme les entreprises avaient
besoin
de journalistes fassent s'adressait à
des journalistes que même rapporter les
propos en les remettant dans le contexte
etc et vous étiez un belligérant si vous
vouliez vous adresser à une opinion d'un
autre pays ou de votre pays allaient
passer par le yas aujourd'hui chacun
tout le monde peut être un média je
pense pas que tout le monde soit
journalistes en revanche tout le monde
peut être un média tout compte sur un
réseau social est un média et donc vous
pouvez être un groupe religieux radical
ou même terroriste au moyen-orient
une entreprise parce qu'au fond c'est la
même chose dans ce qui se passe là sur
les avec les belligérants ça se passe
aussi être les journalistes
d'investigation
s'est dès lors que maintenant dès que
vous êtes un pouvoir
politique économique religieux n'importe
quoi vous pouvez vous intéresser
directement à votre clientèle
à il ya une désintermédiation c'est
désintermédiation qui n'ont elles non je
dis clientèle j'aurais pu dire à votre
public à votre audience à votre
clientèle c'est une manière narquoise de
dire ah ah ah ce à votre public cible
voilà on vous dirait
100 personnes sans vous preniez le
risque que quelqu'un vienne dire que
viennent dû ajouter du contexte à votre
propos dire que votre propos est faux et
aidera
et c'est ce qu'a fait donald trump mais
c'est ce que chacun peut faire
aujourd'hui est ce que font jeudi encore
les entreprises des belligérants tout le
monde
cette désintermédiation qui est
totalement nouvelle mais qui lit à
l'explosion des communications
elle est positive à plein d'égards alors
pas s'agissant des pouvoirs mais ça crée
de la communication horizontale c'est à
dire tout le monde peut s'exprimer
c'était quoi la question c'était les
belligérants mais je veux montrer que
c'est la même chose c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui donc je reviens s'il faudra
court 6 ma réponse
aujourd'hui dès lors que vous pouvez
vous adresser directement à votre public
cible
le gala qui vient et qui vient enfin
gare le journaliste la journaliste qui
vient enquêter qui vient fourrer son nez
qui vient vous opposer des arguments ou
même qui va voir le camp d'en face
qui fait son travail
de tiers de confiance
il vous gêne parce qu'en fait il nuit à
votre propagande donc là où dans les
conflits avant si vous mettiez 11
paradera tv sur votre capot de voiture
ou presse ça vous protéger parce que
aujourd'hui vous êtes gênant un témoin
gênant
ça vaut pour les oignons puisqu'il ya
aussi là je parle des ong humanitaires
et et donc il faut cibler les témoins
gênants ça fait chier pour les
propagandistes témoins gênants
et c'est que ça c'est pas ça alors ça
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des
journalistes qui a été en double carte
avec les services de renseignement c'est
pas parce qu'il y avait des ong qui
était en doublant cartes etc les
services de renseignements jamais et non
mais alors je peux livrer une raison à
mon avis historique enfin un argument
historique
les journalistes au fil de l'histoire
ils sont plutôt détaché de service
d'enseignement
albert londres qui est une figure du
journalisme français étaient acoquiné
avec les habs et renseignements je
connais un photo journaliste du monde
qui a été incarné pendant trente ans que
les services de renseignement il a lâché
qui après disant avoir pris sa retraite
ça doit arriver comme toutes les
professions qu'ils se rendent
moi j'ai fait des papiers quand j'étais
au point sur des ong
hock je me souviens sous influence du
vatican où il y avait beaucoup de gens
des services donc
il pas besoin de regarder bureau des
légendes pour voir que bas-fonds un faux
faux faux sur place voilà il ya eu çà
une affaire an en somalie où des agents
français sont fait passer pour des
journalistes
alors là c'est autre chose mais que ça
puisse arriver peut-être oui mais
quand florence aubenas vas
tu allais en reportage en irak elle y
aller pour son journal le das alors moi
je dis alors jeu là il ya des factures
coeur peut être d'accord revenons à nos
moutons en france les gilet jaune est ce
que quand vous avez vu la police
le ministère de l'intérieur et
j'allais dire ses sbires mais ce n'est
pas le bon mot je dirais c'est ses
assesseurs
agir en france pour encadrer une révolte
est ce que vous avez pu trouver des
similitudes avec les dictatures qu'on
décrète dictature souvent par exemple le
fait de tirer en pleine tête sur des
manifestants est ce que ça vous a fait
penser aux révolutions égyptiennes le
fait d'en cirque li na c'est ça vous a
fait penser aux révolutions égyptiennes
est ce que quand vous avez vu les flics
en moto là ça vous a fait penser un
petit peu comme au chameau qui
débarquait place tahrir avec les bâtons
c'est ça vous n'avez pas ça vous a pas
fait penser à ça
est-ce que les techniques de contre
insurrection françaises sont
semblables on va dire un peu plus policé
parce que quand il faut que ça passe au
20 heures sont à peu près les mêmes que
les techniques de contre insurrection
dans les dictatures
moi je ne crois pas
la cité le cas de l'egypte sur la
famille qu'on connaît très très bien
donc attention abba dont le
général président récemment a eu droit à
notre légion d'honneur en catimini le
drame en catimini
avec nos impôts oui enfin pas si ça
coûte cher à rosette mais lol mon
problème était plutôt de que ça lui
était remis au sénat de faire d'impôts
quand il ya eu
ou même pour remonter avant tiananmen
puisque la chine
des chars d'assaut qui roule sur des
tentes il ya des gens à l'intérieur sur
la place tiananmen
on connaît pas le chiffre du nombre de
tués en juin de 89 mais des milliers
s'en remettra au moins cinq il entoure
pékin
l'egypte
des centaines peut-être pas loin d'un
millier de juifs tués sur la place j'ai
oublié le nom de la place rires non non
non non la place tahrir est
laid en irak la place elle
une répression bref un tiananmen
égyptiens dont on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
je dois dire beaucoup moins enfin pas
dans un rapport deux camps étaient
légitimes
on n'en est pas là en france
faut pas déconner mais la question est
est-ce qu'on est jean genet d'accord je
tiens à le dire parce que sinon je suis
consciente elle soyez content de le dire
mais on vient ici ils ne remettent les
choses on met on pas très non mais je
viens là sûrement des françaises mais
comme la question c'est est ce qu'on est
comme l'egypte ou la chine ou non est ce
que c'est ça y ressemble
nous notre notre ce qui s'est passé il
ya eu des violences policières alors
devenu condé journal si on est contre
des manifestants en général qui sont
inadmissibles qui sont pas simplement
des accidents on va remettre lisions
départ à la violence policière ça fait
penser ou mais qui se prend un petit
coup de bâton sur la tête d'accor non
mais des tirs usant de reflets des gones
à noter qu'en france il ne déplaît pas
bien pour lui déplaire gagné 2 les armes
les ailes bd dans les yeux ça à fond
dans la bouche
et et ça c'est une chose qui est
[Musique]
il ya eu des sens alors s'agit moi ça
juste parce que je connais mieux que les
journalistes pour l'alléger pas
il ya eu des centaines
d'actes de cette sorte là et qui sont
pas le tir
mal ajustée qui sont délibérées
c'est une honte
il ya eu des centaines et ça a commencé
ces violences là elles ont commencé au
moment de l'évacuation de la jungle de
calais
ça s'est poursuivi avec la loi
travailler nuit debout et ça s'est
amplifié avec le mouvement des jeunes et
disons le clairement ces violences
policières qui alors s'agissant des
journalistes et on avait
david dufresne qui était venu au moment
où on a lancé notre classement mondial
de la liberté de la presse et qui
relevait ce qu'on avait relevé aussi que
ces violences elle était à ce moment là
en tout cas le fait de forces de police
qui n'était pas
formés au maintien de l'ordre des forces
supplétives en groupe parce que comme
les flics étaient fatigués enfin jeudi
flic c'est pas péjorer policier était
tiré avec une arme
je lui une fois dans un centre de tir
pour voir à quoi ça ressemblait pour le
reste je suis pas un fana mili ou un fan
d'armes à feu
voilà j'ai répondu à la question
d'accord ça va mieux non mais donc pour
y revenir donc c'était notamment le fait
de ces forces supplétives
mais très clairement ça n'a pas fait
l'objet malgré demande
des sanctions alors il ya eu des
sanctions de l'igpn mais ça n'a pas fait
l'objet de la prise en charge et et même
d'une prise de conscience politique
comme ça aurait dû faire et ça
emmanuel macron
les ministres de l'intérieur successifs
castaner darmanin là-dessus n'ont pas
fait ce qu'ils auraient dû faire c'est à
dire faire en sorte de mettre fin à ces
violences la don alors après christophe
de loin qui secrétaire général de
reporters sans frontières il n'y a pas
eu de similitudes dans la contre
insurrection française avec la
contre-insurrection égyptienne
non mais quand ton juste je pense que
c'est une
ont peut être extrêmement ferme et est
dénoncée avec force ce qui se passe en
france
sans faire
des fausses comparaison mais qui des
similitudes quand on tire sur quelqu'un
c'est similaire
mais juste gmt afin un tout handicap en
démon renard mais évidemment l'ingénieux
handicapant en egypte elle même shoot
handicap en france c'est la même chose
démonstratif mais qu'elle est et tout
mais ça ressemble ou ça ressemble pas
c'est tellement dur à dire mais l'homme
sait pas ce que je dis le même acte
évidemment qui ressemble d'accord après
comparer jeu ce que je dis de manière
très claire eon la d1 en revanche
franchement la dénoncer on allait voir
toutes les personnes comment il avait
fait pour l'animer d'esprit plus de
force comment vous avez fait pour
l'amont a utilisé ce qu'on fait par tout
à fait une kermesse dont vous avez fait
une kermesse
c'est parce qu'on fait
on a communiqué parce que nous notre la
manière dont on travaille c'est que on
introduit des formes de rapports de
force en communiquant par la prise de
parole publique
on va voir tous les gens qu'on peut
aller voir pour plaider cette cause
on a déposé des plaintes quand on a posé
plusieurs plaintes par exemple quant au
préfet de police de paris l'a récemment
sur les dernières manifestations pour
quel objet bas pour des thés des tirs ou
des actes violents de policiers dont des
journalistes et on met à peu près alors
on a déposé trois plaintes au cours des
deux derniers mois
c'est maintenant ce qu'ont été les trois
plantes c'est quand même deux mais trois
points à chaque fois pour plusieurs
personnes ainsi déjà trois plaintes
contre le préfet de police
sans faire d'autres mais mais si ces
sujets là si ces affaires là sont
traités et et dont une sur le faudra si
rien amer
qui qui a été blessé en
près de la place de la bastille
on a
déposé
[Musique]
d on a fait des enquêtes on a déposé des
recours auprès du défenseur des droits
je peux vous dire qu'on a obtenu ce
qu'on voulait non on n'a pas obtenu
par dont vous êtes un peu agitée bah on
a fait ce que ce qui est en notre
capacité de faire nous on n'a pas pas
donné d'ordre aux policiers directement
au genou on va continuer dans le sujet
des manifestations de la couverture de
presse vous êtes un peu chic aux rennais
avec deux autres journalistes dont je
crois bien
si vous faites référence au fait qu'on
s'est fait dans ma vie parce que vous
êtes un peu chicorée avec des
journalistes n'y avait pas mais alors ce
match est tabou 1 c'est ça alors
fait avoir fait que deux personnes enfin
sur ce qui sur une déclaration d'amour
sur twitter déclaration d'amour oui
enfin d'amour haine est plutôt la
deuxième partie moi j'ai pris ça pour
une déclaration d'amour ils sont dit les
gardiens du temple ils sont un petit peu
passive a peut-être
non mais c'est notamment s'agissant de
glandes voilà quelqu'un qui depuis un
spar de son petit nom ah oui mais enfin
on peut dire mais on peut dire les gens
on peut les appeler par leur nom en fait
on l'a fait avec d'autres depuis le
début de la
l'entretien donc c'était pas
bon bah c'est quelqu'un qui nous qui sur
twitter
nous insultent dix femmes tu étais en
voilà et qui est un peu
qui s'émeut qu'on ne défendent pas
attendu à raison
alors c'est quelqu'un qui en première
ligne qu'eux en première ligne nous je
le disais mais en inhalant mais alors je
veux dire on a une vision exigeante
j'aurai donc toute la journée dans
l'ensemble du monde ont fait des choix
sur des gens qu'on défend une autre
qu'on ne le font pas nous on n'a pas
vocation à dire qui est journaliste qui
l'est pas mais en revanche pour nous
mêmes on décide en fonction de critères
et notamment du respect c'est un critère
mais de la fameuse charte de munich
et on pense que l'insulté la diffamation
tout ça ça fait pas partie journalisme
et que si nous on commettrait une erreur
pour l'avenir du journalisme
si d'une manière ou d'une autre on
cautionnait ça c'était dommage ni ne nie
pas le rôle social que peuvent avoir des
gens qui font des images mais certains
sont des voix là dans les manifestations
vous avez des journalistes alors de
différentes sortes de journalistes il ya
des gens qui peuvent être des activistes
c'est quoi des différentes armées
différentes sortes des gens qui
travaillent pour des grands médias
d'autres qui sont
des jeunes débutants ou déjà ne pas
débuter à les entendre les jeunes
journalistes travaillant pour
des sites nouvellement créée et puis
vous avez vous avez aussi des actifs
sains vous êtes allés dans les manifs
bien sûr bon il ya plein de gens qui
filme comme partout et nous on pense
qu'il suffit de notre point de vue pour
notre mandat qu'il suffit pas d'avoir de
filmer pour être un journaliste sinon
honnêtement on finira par défendre des
policiers comme j'en ris parce qu'eux
aussi ils ont fumé donc ça n'a pas de
sens donc nous
journal art qui est toujours dansé dans
son petit appartement pour faire ses
papiers mais moi j'avais franchement
nous on défend des gens qui sont prêts
qu'ils se retrouvent en taule partout
dans le monde notre propre organisation
franchement même nous annonce qu à moi à
moi à titre personnel mais notre
organisation on s'en prend est ce que
c'est un la fille 11 et prend plein la
figure c'est notre correspondante au
mexique balbina qui est menacée de mort
c'est khaled rariny notre correspondant
en algérie qui a été condamné à trois
ans de prison cet été puis à deux ans de
prison et qui
pour rien juste parce il a couvert des
manifestations pour le coup et parce
qu'il ya un journaliste brillant
indépendant qu'il a refusé de céder à
l'intimidation au harcèlement policier
et judiciaire placé en garde à vue plein
de fois
il a refusé de céder à la corruption on
lui a proposé un appartement on lui a
proposé un de diriger l'audiovisuel
d'état je vais dire publiquement fins et
publique d'état
c'est la même chose
et il a été foutu en taule ailier pour
officiellement
incitations attroupement non armés et
atteinte à l'intégrité ou à la
souveraineté
du territoire
et dans les phrases qu'on lui a
reprochées c'est dans les attendus du
jugement en première instance il ya le
fait d'avoir dit
les algériens réclament la liberté de la
presse et on leur répond avec de
l'argent ce qu'ils veulent c'est la
liberté de la presse et
notre correspondant en turquie eyrolles
a fait de la taule ya quelques années
a eu un procès pendant moi je suis allé
je suis pas cette audience sans qu'il en
ait eu dix pendant son procès tout ça
après une procédure hyper langues la
cour d'appel d'istanbul vient d'annuler
son acquittement
bref
donc simplement là en tant
qu'organisation pour revenir à ce propos
voilà nous on a au moment où il ya une
explosion de la communication de la
question s'est posée on a on a
énormément réfléchi à ces questions qui
on est ce qu'on défend tout le monde est
ce qu'on défend tous les cas ce que est
ce qu'on défend tous les gens qui ont un
appareil photo tous les gens qui ont une
caméra tous les gens qui ont un site
internet pour les gens qui ont un compte
twitter etc et on s'est dit si on fait
ça on défend tous non mais on en veut
deux gars qui sont aux premières lignes
tous les week-ends qui se prennent les
gomme-cogne toute la journée des gaz et
au delà total c'est pas le prix qu'un
nom d'ice à ouakam qui en manifestation
c'est le mec qui se fait shooter à
travers trois pantalons il se retrouve
encore avec le caleçon éborgné par le
fbi mais on
non et qui ramène les bonnes images qui
sur le terrain nos yeux et nos oreilles
jamais on peut enfin on peut franchement
c'est pour nous c'est une affaire
évidemment qu'on se fait critiquer que
les des gens qui on compte défend pas
mais où nous en sommes arrive partout
elle franchement qu'ils soient militants
pas militant quoi que ce soit on parle
de gains non mais nous alors nous on
distingue le journalisme alors à ramener
d'informations de première main de la
première ligne
est creux
mais qui le dialogue se fait ciblés par
la police on les entend dire aliagas
parquet l'a oublié pas de l'attraper on
fait ce qu'on fait remy buisine en
devisant baron là on n'a pas déposé
plainte dans l'une des plaintes rond on
a bon dos ça va
nous on a défendu plein de deux
journalistes de terrain quels que soient
leur style d'un gang c'est un
journaliste ou pas d'écoutés en tout cas
c'est quelqu'un qui nous insultent
depuis des années donc c'est un journal
qui profèrent des menaces moi je suis
désolé est ce que c'est un journée quand
on est journaliste on insulte pas ou
n'est ce pas on raconte pas n'importe
quoi
et comme si je raconte n'importe quoi
mais pat
shanahan fin c'est un journaliste oui ou
non mais moi j'aime ça mais moi je suis
pas l'arbitré 2 je suis ni la carte de
presse enfin en journée pour parler de
la carte de moi ils sont parlés dans
l'otan voulait ni moi je dis pas qu'ils
aient journal et ses pages journal jeudi
qui nous on défend et et là on a pris
une décision un jour alors ok est ce que
c'est vrai mais franchement toute la
journée nous en syrie groupes armés
nommer les français sont aux normes il
ya des gens qui les ont déçus on regarde
non pardon la france a ressemblé à un
peu la syrie
non je pense qu'il faut être enfin
franchement faut là dessus je pense
qu'il faut aller à alep et à homs et
avoir vécu ce qui s'est passé c'est pas
la même chose et je pense que tenir ce
discours d'hier c'est pas les prémices
et nous amener vers ça ne dit pas les
prémices il faut pas que ça le soit
je pense qu'on sache ou qui messi qu'on
est d'environ n'a été choqué des gens
qu'ils se fassent défiguré mais
évidemment enfin mais nous on a fait
notre boulot sur notre mandat et nous
notre mandat c'est une journaliste et
enfin on a dû aller contre ça etc etc
ce qui est scandaleux que ça ait lieu et
il faut qu'on trouve un moyen pour que
ça s'arrête et il faut pas que de
nouvelles lois le favoriser et c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est longtemps l'image du
gouffre l'article indéniable que
maintenant l'article 18 de la loi
séparatisme c'est parce que c'est des
lois va deux articles
qui peuvent renforcer
ce que font pas tous les policiers
ce que moi je veux pas être comme
certains syndicats de police qui voyait
nous nous ont insultés parce qu'on
défend des la liberté de la presse
franchement il ya des policiers qui
subissent des violences trop chaud je
peux le dire et c'est sans doute
également le tome 1 de la cites il ya un
plan facile à ses 95
mais ça justifie absolument pas les
violences
au moment où
commencent les débats à l'assemblée
nationale sur l'article 24 qui à la
manifestation juste à cause de
l'assemblée nationale ça c'est un vent
ou après être invité par castex c'est
comme ça avant avant
il ya des policiers qui
tape un journaliste et qu'il lui dise
je vous dit la phrase exacte mais en
gros
tu perd rien pour attendre avec la loi
on va pouvoir avoir son à pouvoir faire
et l'idée que dans cette loi elle
permettait les arrestations en flagrance
et cetera s'étaient donnés
à la police la possibilité d'
instrumentaliser une loi de s'en servir
et d'ailleurs ça c'est un article avait
été inspiré par des cinq quatre
policiers et honnêtement qui avait été
de manière assez démagogique
mais dans une loi en urgence et s'est
fait tout pour
éviter que la police lâche le pouvoir
c'est ça abba semble-t-il c'est le cas
c'est que ça c'est évidemment ça joue
c'est que
quand le pouvoir a peur que la police
l'a ce que la police lâche
il
se montre faible avec elle et qu'on a
besoin d'un ministre de l'intérieur il
demande après dans la khl wiki mettre
les choses dans l'isère
crois pas
kaiser moi ça m'inspire pas bon ça nous
inspire pas non plus que la police ait
tous les pouvoirs vous avez milité pour
retirer qu'un simplement le 24 août où
le dispositif nous on s'est cantonné à
notre mandat
donc les drones et tehran on est
entraînés sur le 24
tirs présentait parce que c'est
maintenant on peut le mettre au passé je
crois enfin
un danger évident
certains policiers je le disais avait
commencé à l'appliquer par anticipation
et heureusement je pense que de ce point
de vue là
s'agissant de la proposition de la
sécurité globale
pense qu'on en est venu à bout enfin
après faut vérifier jusqu'au texte final
ça faut on va rester vigilant mais est
donc la sq ont plus récemment moi j'ai
fait une tribune dans le monde avec
bâtonnier de paris lille et kuzi sur
l'article 18 de la loi séparatisme moi
je conteste pas la légitimité enfin
c'est pas notre gaulage estime ted
global de la loi séparatiste mais cet
article 18 qui a été introduit de
manière pour des raisons différentes la
spa les syndicats de flics c'est plutôt
bien que ça mais le pâtis en fait
il est dangereux parce qu'il inclut
l'article 24 c'est d'une certaine
manière il peut en être fait un usage
même s'il est beaucoup plus large et qui
vise pas à défendre des policiers je
crois pas mais
usage correct effet de l'article 24 il
peut en effet là
donc ça il faut vraiment retirer
l'article 24 de cet article 18 de du
projet de loi séparatiste alors
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à vos
détracteurs qui disent 'voilà
rsf c'est un peu la protection peau de
lapin et des reporters des journalistes
c'est ils ne vivent que de subventions
ils ne publient jamais leur compte on
sait pas quand comment ils gagnent leur
pognon
ils sont le faux nez du gouvernement
pour adouber les lois sécurité
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à ces
gens là même qu'il adore ce qui dit ça
il nous emballe lui la défense pour de
lapin un bon ça s'est excusé vous est
tout le temps dans l'est dans les procès
où quatre coins du monde pour sauver des
journalistes ça je pense vous d'accord
vos finances on reporters sans
frontières ça pèse combien l année ça
paye quel type de taxe c'est financé par
qui on trouve ça ou comment alors nos
conclusions sur notre site
en est reproché récemment d'avoir 40 %
de subventions publiques laissant
entendre que c'était des subventions
publiques françaises et que donc
cqfd on était sous une influence les
subventions publiques françaises et 13 %
de notre budget 2010 9 choisit pas
l'année qui m'arrangerait 2010 9 13%
on a des subventions publiques
de d'âge ans de développement
généralement
suédoise dont tout le royaume uni pays
bas merci un million de dollars n'y a
pas très longtemps un an
vous avez reçu un prix quelque chose
comme ça avant rsf a alors c'est pas
cette bo reçoit parfois des prix oui des
prix avec de l'argent ça peut arriver
combien
quoi combien les combien de prix on vous
donne combien
a nommé sa sé nou l'argent honnêtement
faut se battre pour aller chercher sa g
et qu'on est et et on va pas chercher
n'importe où franchement on a un par
rapport à fin à part ben non pas par
rapport dans l'absolu on a une un modèle
financier qui ne laisse en totale
indépendance et ça je peux l'assurer
partout et les bailleurs c'est à dire
les donateurs pendant que byers
là aucune jeu peu importe qu'ils
essaient de nous influencer et y en a eu
kiki
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure avant
l'entretien google non mais par exemple
google et moi quand je suis arrivé à rsf
la situation financière était
extrêmement dégradée et google donné pas
mal d'argent
il donnait à l'époque 130 millions par
an à peu près enfin ça c'était les
bonnes données je crois
mais moi je voudrais quand même qu'ils
essayaient de me tordre le bras
ben je vous dire comment ça se passe on
a tordu le bras c'est
bon on va donner vous faites ce que vous
voulez mais bon ce serait bien de faire
un rapport certains le suggèrent vous
écrivez ce que vous voulez mais
certaines puis ça serait pas mal mais
mais parce que vous l'aimez serait pas
mal de cas chapitre là dessus et on n'a
jamais cédé mais au bout d'un moment ça
me fait un peu mal au bras là où coude
et donc je suis allé les voir je vais
devoir le gars qui sont occupés à
londres et en lui disant moi j'en veux
plus
face à idra bien évidemment tu veux il a
dit quoi alors moi je dois être honnête
la tchèque c'est que je n'ai jamais
déterminé si c'était une politique de
google où les gens avec qui on était en
contact même si honnêtement
combien on sait les plateformes
numériques de manière générale ont une
capacité on l'a vu au moment des
discussions sur les droits voisins au
parlement européen ont une capacité de
s'attirer enfin les bonnes grâces par
par différents moyens ou dissuader ceux
qui m'est très fort
donc voilà on prend pas on il ya des
évidemment des pays on prend pas
l'argent public mais on prend l'argent
public dans les pays où il ya on peut
critiquer le pouvoir et voilà où il n'y
a pas de lien et
peut-être que certains
des gens qui nous suivent se diront mais
on a des financements privés là aussi
dans plein de pays différents
transparence et qui alors pas tous les
détails mais oui c'est transparent oui
on a des grandes fondations
internationales
on a
quelques mécènes des individus
et transparent et celui je peux me dire
ce qu'ils nous donnent le plus il
s'appelle craig newmark vous connaissez
peut-être parce que son prénom est
connue puisque c'est lui qui a fondé
l'équivalent du bon coin américain
craigslist
non je sais pas si vous avez ou ces voix
là bas lui nous soutient combien up
alors lui nous a soutenus sur des
projets spécifiques qui nous a donné pas
mal
sur deux ans il nous a donné un million
cinq cent mille dollars
mais voilà donc mais franchement alors
faut se battre honnêtement mais il nous
a pas il n'a pas
influencé d'une quelconque juste nous on
arrive on dit voilà ce qu'on fait
est-ce que ça
on a le grand public qui nous donne
beaucoup les campagnes de fin d'année
ont fait des spots à la télé on obtient
la gratuité pour passer les spots enfin
on ce bac franchement on a des moyens
modestes par rapport à ce qu'on fait en
fait on est là ça paraît peut-être des
sommes très importantes votre
fonctionnement l'année c'est combien la
structure parisienne ses 6 millions
d'euros
personne il ya quarante salariés à paris
et maintenant on a des bureaux on s'est
beaucoup développée à l'international
alors le siège est à paris on s'est
beaucoup développée on a des bureaux
dans quatorze villes dans le monde avec
des salariés on a des correspondances
entre amp et donc on est maintenant une
organisation de taille moyenne mais qui
qui se bat partout en fait notre notre
originalité si je puis dire et ce qui je
crois a fait notre force c'est c'est
faire le grand écart c'est à dire c'est
d'être à la fois sur le terrain
dans les valises d'afghanistan à créer
un centre pour les femmes d'afghanes à
kaboul à sortir des journalistes
de la région de deraa est maintenant de
notre région mais je serais plus discret
là dessus de syrie
et dans les lieux où il ya ce qu'on
appelle en anglais les décisions makers
ceux qui prennent des décisions pour
essayer de les influencer et
c'est comme ça qu'on obtient des
résultats et donc moi je sais parce que
même quand j'étais dans une rédaction
vous structures mondiales sait combien
de fonctionnement donc c'est au total
une dizaine de millions pour l'ensemble
du monde oui
et on a voilà mes mais gym fiscal vous
avez un souci alors on est une
association enfin en fait on a besoin
pour compliqué on a deux associations en
france dans l'une est reconnue d'utilité
publique
et
est en fait moi quand j'étais dans une
rédaction quand je dis moi j'étais
journaliste dans un des domaines erreur
de socios perception d'aller porter
plainte contre deux journalistes qui
sont en première ligne à supporter
l'adrénaline
pour un vieux journaliste non mais qui
va peut être bienveillant est ce qu'il y
avait pas un moyen d'arranger les choses
mais quand vous avez agi parce que
c'était la meilleure idée du monde
honnêtement on l'a pas fait d'ailleurs
mais mais quand vous avez des gens qui
est 2 en balance n'importe quoi sur le
net
je suis pas si ça arrive notre bonne
évoqué ces dernières voilà donc c'est un
peu ça c'est des avancées que comment
vous défendez même quand vous êtes de
bonne fin moi j'ai vu toutes sortes de
choses on a alors d'ailleurs avec des
choses parfois amusantes à des gens
qu'ils est bon rsf rsf france les
comptes twitters c'est vraiment des
décrets ont été vendus mais alors rsf
inter ils sont super les gens qu'ils ne
se rendent pas compte et les mêmes
personnes
voilà et on voit tous que j'ai acheté
mes diplômes que j'ai
pour acheter vos diplômes bas donc je
les ai pas beaucoup acheté j'ai bossé on
peut les avoir mais et donc
il ya un moment vous êtes un peu
désarmée et même en tant qu'organisation
et voilà après c'est franchement c'est
par rapport à ce qu'on fait dans
l'ensemble du monde c'est pas c'est pas
ce qui m'obsède moi toute la journée ni
quand ni moi ni l'ensemble de l'équipe
qui bossent honnêtement qu'il ya eu qu'à
pas apprécier ce genre de critiques qui
se dit mince enfin toi vu
l'énergie la détermination qui est mise
le truc pour essayer d'obtenir des
résultats partout sortir des mecs de
tôle les évacuer leur faire des
formations
obtenir des meilleures lois à lutter
contre les lois scélérates
enfin on fait ça partout
on essaie vraiment de boxer au dessus de
notre catégorie
et
je pense que c'est pas un hasard si les
journalistes aux philippines en inde
partout il
il considère que reporters sans
frontières est là pour les aider et
franchement
les mecs en somalie et savent qu'une
organisation derrière et pas qu'en ce
malien qu'on dise pas ouais alors vous
vous occupez que de la somalie dont
s'occupe du monde entier mais on se bat
lille en vient on vient d'obtenir en
somalie un moratoire sur les
arrestations de journalistes qui est on
revient aux questions déontologiques
voilà ce que quand même pour rapprocher
de situation je suis allé c'est
peut-être une des villes les plus
dangereuses du monde chez elle à
mogadiscio depuis l'automne la octobre
devront accompagner ou juste tous nab
avec notre responsable arrivent
d'afrique arnaud projet mais que tous
les deux jambes billets secs son fixeur
sur place ou avec le plus bas dans la
surface on a une organisation qu'est
notre organisation partenaire qui
s'appelle la nusoj qui est une
organisation de journalistes et donc sur
place
ils vont aider à calais les rendez vous
entre
nous un parcours fléché c'était comment
s'annonce prêt fléché offre enfin le
seul truc monégasque yeux c'est que vous
avez pas faire du shopping quand vous
balader là pour le coup c'est que des
mecs armés en convoi fenêtres blindées
c'est l'hôtel l'hôtel j'étais juste à
côté de la zone verte il y avait 3 sas
pour entrer dans l'hôtel tellement c'est
bon et donc vous êtes là ils vont
rencontrer des jeunes journalistes et
j'en serais je vous coupe les mecs
question la sécurité c'est un marché
privé c'est vous qui lisez engagé
comment ça se passe ah bah là on a on à
rémunérer des gens pour nous de protéger
ce site et privés
à combien je crois que ça nous a coûté
quatre mille euros 4,5 euros dans
l'après midi non pour une prestation sur
deux trois jours mais notamment un
trajet engagés dans ces deux pays à ccc
dément enfin on n'imagine pas dans
quelles conditions les gens vivent dans
une news comme ça kaka était une des
perles de l'afrique mais vous s'engager
dans ces cas-là un médiateur au cas où
si vous fait kidnapper un négociateur
quelque chose comme ça vous avez une
assurance maintenant je dois dire que
j'ai j'ai reçu un coup de fil du du quai
d'orsay avant de partir pourquoi ici
tout commence à bien dit inquiet qu'on y
aille parce que eux les isole à 6,6 et
obésité pas au courant non mais comme
ils ont su hannon alors si si pardon
il ya un dispositif sur le site depuis
d'orsay où vous rentrez vous vous mettez
enfin quand vous allez dans des zones
extrêmement dangereuses et vous donner
quelques indications pour que s'il ya un
truc parce que chacun sait qu'en cas de
prise d'otages toujours au début
enfin tout l'essentiel se joue au début
c'est à dire quelque chose peut être
dénoué dans les premières heures
10 millions $ ca des nous tous dans les
premiers je pense pas je pense quand il
ya eu et j'ai eu des rançons je pense
que ça a pris du temps quand même avant
de les sortir mais c'est pas une serment
la france qui les a sortis ou pardon à
mon argent en ce moment c'est pour ça
mais mais je vais le dire parce que là
bas j'ai rencontré des jeunes
journalistes
beaucoup tablent d'ailleurs des jeunes
femmes
sur la gr blement surpris
et ils sont dans une situation où il ya
d'un côté les milices shebab qui les
dézingue moi j'ai rencontré le patron
d'une radio
radio
shabelle pardon pardon non radio
shabelle
les 27 journalistes tués les uns après
les autres tous puis un autre puis un
autre puis un autre
et donc ils ont d'un côté les mini
shebab qui est trop lucide et de l'autre
côté les forces de sécurité qui avaient
sur les arêtes et les tortures et bien
là bas on allait obtenir et à force de
négociations avec
parce qu'on avait rencontré l'ancien
président parce qu'on est allé voir là
parce qu'on a entrepris des équations
avec la présidence qu'on aille voir le
président le pr nice un moratoire sur
les arrestations de journalistes par les
forces de sécurité
ça c'est un exemple
de syrie on a on a sorti des
journalistes voient la dune c'est hyper
dur de sortir des jeux en réseaux
sociaux et parce qu'en fait il faut
l'évacuation de faux le terrain mais il
faut aussi des pays pour les accueillir
vivement que la turquie ouvre les
frontières c'est ça notre boulot chaque
et donc je reviens à ça moi quand
j'étais au point j'étais journaliste
dans l'hebdomadaire le point parfois je
croyais que rsf en gros c'était des mecs
à paris qui sortaient les banderoles
faisait monter pris des otages
c'est quoi ça
alors on sort du moment où on introduit
des rapports de force par
la communication publique par notre la
signature
mais derrière on va négocier on va et à
tous les niveaux aussi le cas pour
julian assange pardon vous avez négocié
quoi pour julian assange dans bad julian
assange en a pas
hugo cie à proprement parler fait des
bonds drôle on a alors on a été l' ong
je dis bien l'omg l apostrophe cas le
plus défendu à son gela au cours de
toutes les auditions la seule ong qui
avait quelqu'un vous a tant besoin
moisson chez quelqu'un que je connais je
suis à l'aise ou allemand oui je vais
enfin je vais le voir plusieurs fois
j'ai dîné 3 4 fois avec lui à
l'ambassade equateur c'était un cinoche
alors entrer dans l'ambassade d'équateur
là vous sentiez les agents partout
depuis des révélations les types qui
étaient à l'intérieur de l'ambassade de
services de sécurité espagnols recruté
par les services de rafael correa a
travaillé pour la cia
notez tout il y avait des caméras bon ça
j'ignorais
et puis vous aviez des camions avec des
antennes façon à avion au boixe devant
le
devant l'ambassade équateur et donc moi
j'ai eu une longue conversation avec lui
c'est un ticket enfin qui vient des
milieux du hacking
d'australie et kaka
une vraie vision politique un idéal et
son idéal aînés de quelque chose auquel
vous parlez au tout début de l'entretien
et va pas parler que les asymétries
informationnel c'est le fait quand
j'étais l'information et le pouvoir
c'est le fait que quand il ya des
asymétries informationnel quand la
détention de l'information
n'est pas également répartie ça crée des
distorsions dans le fonctionnement
politique ou dans le fonctionnement
économique ou sociale etc et pardon je
peux je vois que derrière la caméra ça
s'agite
artisanaux d'ici alors assange s'est pas
saigner un enjeu
neil démons qui étaient déguisées
absolument pas tout ce qu'il a fait
il a fait des choses
qu'on peut ne pas apprécier iliad espère
néanmoins
deux choses sont sûres 1
depuis la sphère suédoise il ya eu la
construction
d'une image extrêmement négatif et d'un
diable et qui a été une construction
artificielle
j'ai pas pu et par faire des anciens
proches qu'il adore et qui met où on lui
a on a construit une image
du violeur et c est
ça il ya un rapport d'un d'un rapporteur
spécial de l'onu nils meltzer 1 suisse 1
qu'il démontre absolument et puis
surtout l'enjeu si nous on a défendu
c'est que heu on pense que son
extradition représenterait un danger
majeur pour le journalisme
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ce qui est
visé c'est journalisme c'est ce qu'il a
fait alors nous on dit pas que assange
est journaliste or certains peuvent le
prêt à le dire au sens où il a aidé
historia lisez y compris la première
vidéo collatéral freedom il a fait des
recherches médicales des matchs
collatéral à wind en collatéral freedom
c'est une opération confère rsf où on
débloque des sites censurés par an
et
il
met ses il a été un intermédiaire cette
année niant whistleblower c'est pas lui
le lanceur d'alerté lanceurs d'alertés
manning
enfin manning et d'autre mais l'huile et
une intermédiaire et les surnoms imagés
dit manning comme j'ai dit
les noms et pour ne pas parce que
récemment alors chelsea qui à l'époque
des faits s'appelait bradley mais reza
manger j'utilise mon prénom on leur fait
un malheureux mais aujourd'hui chelsea
manning et qui
est donc mais assange il a
il a contribué au journalisme
et ça c'est incontestable il est
poursuivi pour ça et c'est pour ça que
son extradition ferait peser un danger
majeur ne l'est déjà depuis patriot act
il ya eu un élargissement aux états unis
de touchants qui est couvert par la
sécurité nationale
qui portent atteinte aux journées des
investigations il ya des grands
journalistes du new york times james
dyson qu'on a défendu qui ce qu'on était
poursuivi notamment sur la base de
textes y compris des textes de temps de
guerre mais ce que najac tu qui remonte
à 1917 que obama a réactivé ce patronne
qui a fait ça c'est obama
et
moi je
par exemple suis allé voir alors c'était
il ya un an ou deux owen poho new york
times dans cet immense building à new
york le general console c'est le juriste
en chef
et je lui dis
c'est quoi pour vous le plus grand
danger pour le journalisme aux états
unis et à l'époque il m'a répondu un
donald trump quand même c'est évident
comme ap2 la possible extradition de
julian assage et pourtant je dois dire
que nous on a un bureau à washington on
n'est pas très compris aux etats-unis
c'est-à-dire l'opinion américaine est
vraiment remonté contre assange
mais dans les médias américains
même ceux qui ont pris leurs distances
avec assange il ya la perception que
c'est un danger donc c'est pour ça qu'on
qu'on l'a défendu moi je vais aller à la
première audience à londres et le jour
où j'allais à la première audience bon
l'huile était derrière des enfin traiter
vraiment comme un terroriste comme s'ils
étaient dangereux alors que ma
conscience c'est quelqu'un de faible à
force de ça fait longtemps qu'il est
dans
qui en réclusion alors on dira oui c'est
lui qui a choisi deux enfin c'était
parce qu' une procédure c'est la torture
alors c'est l'expression utilisée par
nils melzer qui a un aspect torture
psychologique et oui un aspect torture
psychologique moi le jour où je suis
allé à la première audience de
l'extradition là
il a été fouillé 11 fois sur les chemins
de sa cellule dont plusieurs fouilles au
corps
donc
donc oui un aspect torture psychologique
le fait qu'ils soient dans une cellule
il ya des problèmes de chauffage
c'est pour continuer dans
la torture s'est passé pourquoi ça je
sais pas sur l'épreuve de chauffage je
vais pas faire semblant de savoir j'en
sais rien
enfin pour être honnête j'étais au
courant fin donc je mets mais
[Musique]
il ya une telle angoisse face à
à ce type de révélations et à sang chaud
comme quelqu'un qui a permis à certaines
des petits qui par rapport aux
répercussions que le bras armé américain
pourrait vous faire subir si vous
accorder l'asile où c'est une ambassade
lorsque la part des états européens oui
après moi j'étais convaincu qu'ils
avaient une chance qui ne soit pas
extradé parce que ce serait une
humiliation pour les britanniques et les
britanniques sont jamais rien de cela
dans l'unique il passe après
l'humiliation des britanniques
ils ont leur fierté
et il ya un truc c'est qu'il ya je crois
dix fois plus d'extradition dans un sens
que dans l'autre c'est toujours dans le
même sens et que ça à la fin ça fait
beaucoup et puis surtout il ya eu un
épisode de peut-être sans mémoire
jeudi où je dis tu enfin bon qui est une
diplomate américaine qui a tué un enfant
en voiture parce qu'elle conduisait part
comment est il américains au lieu de la
laisser traduire en justice en montagne
ont évacué là donc ça ils l'ont gardé en
travers de la gorge
donc j'espère quand même qu'on y
arrivera après d'ailleurs rappelle donc
c'est parce que le reconduire à la fin
mai allez faire si c'est extra dit une
petite grève de la faim vous allez
mettre des petits drapeaux des kermesses
de lafarge y aurait beaucoup de choses
dans le monde pour lesquels on pourra la
faire mais je
[Musique]
on se battra aux états unis et l'enjeu
sera d'aller faire comprendre aux
médias américains qu'il faut le défendre
alors faire comprendre d'accord mais
dans le rapport de forces est ce qu'il
ya un moment est radicalisée nous
restait toujours dans les clous et
non n'est pas explicitement éthique
banderole
inquiétudes en armes et qui demandera je
suis
là pour aller de rariny notre jeu on a
certes une bâche de 350 m² faut alerter
du budget pour ça
non mais faut aller retrouver enfin faut
se battre pour faire ça a enfin trouvé
à chaque fois qu'on fait un truc faut se
battre c'est pas l'idée sa tombe moi non
on a une équipe qui se démène partout
pour pour trouver les moyens de
c'est quand vous voulez libéré en
mauritanie un mec été condamné à mort
parce que il a
pour apostasie
faut se battre qu'est ce que vous pensez
du fait que nos associations religieuses
en france et du mal à signer le fait
qu'on soit un post 1
ils ont fini par le faire nous on avait
après charlie hebdo le faire c'est
magnifique non mais là vous parlez du
cfcm bas non mais moi je suis pas alors
moi j'ai écrit un bouquin sur ces sujets
en 2004 donc moi je sais pas ce qui se
passe depuis moi j'ai pas l'habitude de
donner mon opinion sur tout j'ai quand
même un peu des scrupules à deux
journalistes et je parle de ce que j'ai
ce dont je suis capable de parler donc
largué sa maman j'ai regardé très loin
comme un lecteur je n'ai rien voilà je
veux pas être le mec qui donne des
leçons alors qu'il ne sait rien de plus
j'ai pas te fait particulière apportée
moi je sais que j'ai fait un bouquin de
d'investigation en 2004 sur
l'extrémisme islamiste et dans lequel à
l'époque on avait révélé pas loin de 200
250 documents secret défense
quand tu n'es pas des directeurs des
services je tiens à dire si c'est la
prochaine question et que vous êtes
journaliste d'investigation vous sortez
parfois des boues 15 et des pièces des
trucs et on vous dit c'est pas grave
on perd tout ça est pas parce que le pou
design pour apporter la pièce la preuve
le truc multi veut pas voir
politique ou une partie où les électeurs
ou
parce que d'une certaine manière il ya
quand même que je veux dire c'est le
politique comme les médias et enfin
comme et les médias je ne fais pas de
sont aussi le reflet de la société du
public alors plus qu'on ne croit
et ça c'est bon on développera cela plus
tard si vous l'aimez et donc
ouais je pense que quand on l'a écrit et
pas beaucoup de gens pour écrire ça et
que malheureusement ce sera avec guillou
oui enfin je veux qu'on soit six heures
plus tôt comme auvergnats parce que j'ai
vécu dans l'allier va donc vous
connaissez pas le ratafia
le ratafia c'est le foie gras
le cas snowdon oui on en est où
passent nos donne je donne c'est
quelqu'un avec qui on travaille aussi
puisque on travaille en direct ou vous
passez par son avocat alors nous on a
fait
d'abord quand snowdon est arrivé à
l'aéroport moscou moi j'avais fait une
tribune à l'époque dans plein de joueurs
internationaux avec avec qu'on avait
cosigné avec julian assange et
on travaille avec ses avocats mais on
quand on a sorti le dernier classement
mondial de la liberté de la presse en
mai dernier on a on a fait une
conférence de presse ou à distance
il y avait ce nous donne et et
voilà mais
là aussi et et snowdon et quelqu'un je
dois dire mais j'ai vraiment beaucoup
d'admiration pour ce modèle qui est
quelqu'un qui a une vision très acérées
de ce que doit être le journalisme
est un profond respect enfin il a et et
je trouve qu'il est enfin quand on
regarde le film de laura poitras sur ce
qui se passe c'est quelqu'un cas
il a le courage de ses idées et il a des
idées fortes et pertinente et chapeau
quoi
mais là en face il ya du lourd en face
un c'est qu'ils en fassent maintenant
mais en face là bas pour eux c'est le
gouvernement des états unis et l'opinion
américaine
et on est dans cette situation
absolument paradoxale où c'est poutine
qui lui offre alors peut-être pas le
gîte et le couvert dans tout cas qui le
protège qu'il protège et c'est vrai que
quand quand ils et s'était retrouvé donc
à l'aéroport à moscou nous ce qu'on
avait demandé avec assange c'est que
l'asile soit faire par l'europe à snow
dome
hills aurait été la moindre des choses
as quand même le mec qui a révélé que
vivait sur louis planète
bah on vit on se bat
on peut avoir le fils pourquoi d'évasion
pessimisme pour la pensée optimisme de
l'action facile ce n'est pas normal dans
onze bas
c'est pourquoi les européens n'ont pas
pu aller oui parce que j'ai inscrit en
gros on est en short mais je sais bien
moi j'en ai parlé avec tes j'en ai parlé
à
quelqu'un qui a été candidat
je ne vois pas qui mêle à la
présidentielle pourquoi je dirais pas
qu'ils
moscou
et et et l'huile mais quand même alors
la plantation était duration sur assange
de snowdon oui je le jeu
moi je suis complètement d'accord sur le
fond mais on s'en prendre à trop la
gueule de la part des états unis et je
pense que c'est ça qu'elle va ta télé
des responsables politiques
revenons à nos moutons
vous faites comment pour protéger votre
vous enquête en termes d'un de numérique
en fait comment pour pas vous faire
pirater vos bécanes vous faites comment
pour vérifier que vous n'êtes pas vers
l'est depuis un certain nombre d'années
vous faites comment pour prodiguer ses
conseils à vous à vos journalistes vous
utilisez quoi et est ce que vous êtes ap
le riz de par l'aspect invasif de deux
des services de renseignement
va par le
lasso statut riante et le capitalisme
surveillance
parce qu'il ya des services
d'enseignement d'un côté
et puis à
face se protéger vis à vis des services
d'enseignement si on est espionné par
des sociétés privées qui peuvent
utiliser notre données à des fins
commerciales le transmettra des services
etc enfin on sert pas à grand chose donc
nous on a été pionnier rsf dans la
formation des journalistes à la sécurité
numérique
on a organisé des ateliers sécurité
numérique partout dans le monde on
travaille avec
pour tester nos dispositifs je parlais
tout à l'heure d'une opération qui
s'appelle collatéral freedom là où c'est
dans des pays ou des sites internet
sont censurés
on les réactive en fait en utilisant
les serveurs de
deux sociétés qui ont une telle taille
que le coût économique serait trop élevé
pour l'état si supprimer le serveur donc
on cherche des alliés qui veulent bien
héberger et donc on redonne une nouvelle
adresse on fait des copies des sites et
pour ça pour les pour tester la capacité
technique on travaille avec des des
hackers notamment et que la cantine de
brest
les connaître
et
donc on fait ça
on est alors moi parfois on est face à
des mois je
la vois je suis allé en chine c'est
justement de prendre les fonctionnaires
à cette intense et difficile mais
c'était justement et et la voyez des
dissidents et les tipis sont fatalistes
et
et il laisse le portable sur la table et
c
est bon après ils ont un courage immense
on n'a pas les juger mais met donc on
fait de la sensibilisation de la
formation
on a fait alors ça on ne fait plus mais
on a fait des livraisons de vpn sous
forme d'un peu de prises électriques si
je puis dire dans des pays où on ne peut
pas utiliser ou la bande passante est
pas suffisante pour que le vpn tiennent
les dpn qu'on utilise chez nous
bref on essaye c'est un sujet sur lequel
on travaille beaucoup et puis on
travaille là sur le plan plus juridique
sur la législation sur les technologies
à double usage technologies militaires
qui peuvent faire l'objet du visage
civil
on a
obtenu en obtenir une décision très
importante de la cour de karlsruhe qui
est le
nôtre juridiction allemande sur les
la surveillance généralisée par
la service de renseignement allemand et
là on vient d'avoir une décision
d'affaires une décision la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme la cour
de strasbourg vient d'annoncer qu'elle
avait jugé recevable une requête qu'on a
déposé sur ces sujets là
bref c'est un sujet qui est évidemment
essentiel parce que
nous on défend et qui sont
d'indépendance de liberté des
journalistes mais aussi leur sécurité et
leur sécurité physique et il ya beaucoup
de journalistes ont été tués
aussi il est question là dessus de la
protection des informations de la
protection des sources des journalistes
mais aussi des journalistes qu'on ont
été tués parce que leur communication
avait été fait l'objet d'interception on
a pu savoir qui il était on peut
balancer ensuite un peu de feu explique
et en syrie des cas comme ça
qu'est ce que vous utilisez
personnellement vous alors
moi quand place tahrir c'est en egypte
nous veut supplanter oui
oui à la grande place mais le fait qu en
gym conneries
alors là je fais mon mea culpa un bon un
vrai
fou non mais
non mais j'étais
bon allez n'entrons pas là dedans
oui j'ai dit une grosse bêtise bon merci
de l'avoir relevé
et
qu'est ce que je disais ah bah oui ça
m'a coupé le sifflet tout ça on
l'utilisé quoi on était sûr vous
utilisez quoi
ça dépend des circonstances
mais
dans les circonstances les plus extrêmes
tout simplement on y va tous nus quoi
faut lé
avec un téléphone totalement propre
comme on dit dans le jargon un
ordinateur qui n'a jamais servi
et on utilise plusieurs couches
vpn
mais s'agit messagerie évidemment
cryptée
gvt messages cryptés jafri
chiffres et
chiffrer
et déchiffrer
le cryptage bon enfin peut on pas et
donc
voilà on essaie d'adapter parce que en
fait c'est toujours un arbitrage
entre
le fait qu'il faut pas que d'adapter la
lourdeur de la protection parce que la
protection c'est toujours un
investissement notamment en temps et les
enjeux est ce que vous connaissez
quelqu'un qui s'appelle jacques marie
bourget à lui alors c'est voilà
quelqu'un qu'on a défendu pendant près
de dix ans
c'est un ancien journaliste de match qui
a été blessé en israël et qu on a arrêté
de défendre ses parts qui alors par les
forces israéliennes
qui fait l'objet de tirs
au bout de 10 ans
et savais pas
je crois je crois que c'était avant mon
arrivée
on a dû arrêter et depuis lens conçoit
de l'amertume donc il écrit beaucoup sur
google alors je peux vous assurer alors
je peux même vous dire il écrit que
j'allais chercher des valises de billets
chez
non pas omar bongo mais son fils il son
prénom à l'instant
ali bongo il écrit toutes sortes de
choses comme ça et mes oeufs
et il est fâché quoi il est fâché puis
le cul des choses qui n'ont aucun
rapport à ses lointains avec la réalité
et on voit là mais
je pense que là on est haut
on est au delà du caractère fâché
question internet pourquoi ses slips
turquie autre qui s'indignent lorsque
des journalistes ont baissé en france et
pas rs france exemple 5 décembre 2019 ou
moins 25 en une journée et plusieurs
gravement blessé mais assure qu'ils
ccsf haute cour enfin la personne 30
janvier les salariés de reims et paris
c'était quand même plus classe que rsf
france
mais séparés cette france en fait ça ça
n'existe pas ça existe dans les deux
critiques à rsf est allé s'acheter les
mêmes gens partout alors il ya des gens
positionné à l'étranger etc
il ya des comptes on a des comptes non
publiés tous les joueurs dans de
multiples langues en publie tous les
jours en français en anglais en
arabe enfin si en espagnol
pratiquement en russe et c'est donc
voilà il rend compte qu'ils sont
internet je veux pas c'est qu'ils sont
c'est à vous donner l'opportunité aux
questions internet ça paye plus de
défendre des journalistes étrangers
pourquoi pas des français j'ai pas
compris en gros ça frise plus de de
défendre des journalistes étrangers
pourquoi pas des français
jusqu'à une perception nous on est
on travaille partout et on fait la même
chose partout
on en fait évidemment plus en france que
dans certains pays et je veux dire qu'on
en fait beaucoup plus que par le passé
parce que en gros jusqu'à la fin juste
avant 2010 rsf ne parlait jamais de la
france
savait était même un choix de se dire il
faut une forme de bases arrière sans
vraiment inquiéter notre place nous avec
oui
et et voilà c'est un choix qui avait une
qui pouvaient être contestés qui
d'ailleurs à l'époque avait été contesté
en interne qui a valu des débats très
fort en conseil d'administration aimé qu
avait aussi ça a ses raisons d'être
maintenant on parle de plus en plus de
la france
et ça je sous tous ses aspects on s'est
battu pour i télé
a été un grand succès je dois le dire
mais on s'est battu avec force pour
l'indépendance quitter les camps bolloré
a mis en place son système est rachetée
canal+
sur la loi secret des affaires on s'est
battu et on a obtenu au niveau européen
pioli from faux français alors une
exemption insuffisante mais en gros
pour l'exercice de la liberté
d'expression c'est dans la loi c'est
dans le
insuffisante parce qu'en fait ça
s'applique qu'au moment de la décision
ne s'applique pas ce qu'on appelle
juridiquement au moment de l'instant
c'est ce s'applique pas dans le cas de
la procédure donc
malheureusement ça peut prévoir des
procédures qui sont diligentées
là sur les lois artix 24 en france bas
on s'est battu pour nouvelles garanties
en matière d'indépendance éditoriale qui
sont pas suffisants enfin
voilà on fait alors c'est sûr et j'ai vu
des tweets de des journalistes partout à
paris ou ailleurs kim et moi ils n'ont
pas cité dans cession peut on cite pas
tout le monde mais la question c'est pas
qu'on cite tout le monde et on peut pas
et moi je comprends que des gens disent
mince pourquoi moi ils m'ont pas cité
mais juste
avec la meilleure volonté du monde on
peut pas citer tout le monde la question
c'est est ce qu'on obtient ce qu'on veut
et franchement plein de fois on échoue
mais plein de fois enrichi question
d'internet est-ce qu'il ne distinguerait
pas plus tous les encartés dénonçant
cartes non alors là non dans les deux
sens d'ailleurs d'abord parce que dans
la plupart des parts des pays du monde
n'y a pas de faire de presse c'est un
dispositif français donc faut pas avoir
l'impression que c'est partout pareil
2 nous on a toujours dit ça vous quelque
chose avec la caisse alors ça vaut oui
je dis pas que ça vaut rien
mais c'est une définition droit du
travail
qui est lié à votre rémunération de la
part d'une entité qui est reconnu comme
un média lors des fonctions différentes
pendant sept oui alors c'est du statut
différent évidemment en fonction de
l'audiovisuel la presse écrite et est
donc au fond c'est une forme de
définition tautologique et et
journaliste celui qui exerce au
journalisme dans un média
nous il ya des pays où la carte c'est
juste les médias officiels
donc il ya des gens qui peuvent avoir la
carte nous on conçoit pas comme
journaliste et alain woerth on n'a
jamais réclamé quelqu'un d'avoir la
carte de journaliste pour le défendre si
on considère qu'il faut le défendre
mais il ya des journalistes crt
bien sûr le fait qu'ils soient pas
accréditée pour aller réaliser c'est
important ce pas important ils ont quand
même la carte de presse ça reste des
journalistes ou pas
bien sûr qu'ils aient des journalistes
et même des très bons et des animateurs
et frédéric taddeï qu'un excellent
animateur que vous avez reçus moi
j'adore
rt qu'est-ce que s'écarter
rt participe du pluralisme à l'intérêt
d'avoir une vision que c'est comme erté
erté à aix rachat today
moi je trouve que on a besoin on est
dans un moment où on parlait d'
enfermement au début dans les bulles on
est tous dans nos bulles et notamment
dans nos visions nationales
les médias américains mais d'une
certaine manière les médias français
peut-être légèrement moins mais quand il
ya un conflit baril porte la vision il
ya des proximités ya pas de
nécessairement de manipulation mais il
ya une forme de proximité avec les
sources qui fait que vous épousez plutôt
la cause des sources et que vous avez et
puis vous avez et donc que et une
légitimité à à ne pas avoir une vision
trop américaine du monde trop propre et
au centre et que récemment il ya eu des
accusations moi je connais pas du tout
la réalité des choses sur le fait qu'il
y aurait des victimes civiles au mali de
la part de bombardements français
c'est sûr qu'on en a moins parlé que si
la suspicion elle était sûre voilà enfin
quand je dis on les médias français
le public est moins intéressé aux
sillons c'est là que ça renvoie
est donc
dans tous les pays on a tendance à avoir
des chaumes ski
pardon noam chomsky grand linguiste mais
grand critique des médias
a beaucoup développé notamment dans son
bouquin qui s'appelle la fabrique du
consentement
ah ouais moi aussi j'adore chomsky et
on a défendu ensemble des journalistes
en turquie et je pense qu'il parle de
cette distinction entre les victimes
intéressante et les victimes demandent
intéressante alors lui d'ailleurs expand
son grand exemple j'avais le site et
parce que c'est celle dans les années
70 non 80
il y a
un père qui a dessiné en pologne donc
communiste le père popieluszko
et puis il ya 13 religieux assassiné au
salvador au même moment dwan archevêque
romero
et dans la presse américaine il ya cent
fois plus d'articles sur popieluszko que
romero parce que salvador alors
peut-être parce que c'est un peu comme
un sans gêne à venir en ce moment non
oui oui basse etc afin e
pardon je comprends mal la question
25000 papier sur navalni et il travailla
plus sur assange
oui on pourra dire ça après je sais pas
s'il faut les renvoyer mais mes navalni
bon en plus la manie ses gamins bon
c'est un responsable politique dont le
quart est pas à créer un parfum parties
concernées dans un très bon quand même
c'est surtout unique et huila s'agissant
du journalisme pardon c'est surtout un
mec qui avait insulté les musulmans de
cafard comme ça non ah je pense que
c'est un nationaliste russe aussi mais
moi je
c'est quelqu'un qui fait des enquêtes
montrent qu'on sida près comme
journaliste en revanche à l'aéroport à
moscou là où l'aéroport où il était
censé arriver où les pas arrivé parce
que évidemment pas parce que pouvoir
russe a fait en sorte qu' il y ait le
moins de publicité possible à son
arrivée ils sont quand même un peu con
coup non mais pour eux c'était pas très
malin parce qu'en fait ce soir là dessus
il faut peut-être qu'on revienne la
recherche today parce que j'ai pas
développé là dessus
ils ont arrêté neuf journalistes pour
qu'ils puissent pas présent pas
donc russia today cetc
a été créée dans le cadre quand même
d'une d'une vision guerre de
l'information il ya un général proche de
poutine qui a fait la doctrine faut
mener des guerres de l'information c'est
qui alors fait parvenir une connerie
comme tout à l'heure donc
non je rigole jeans à un privé non alors
j'ai encore en tête mais honnêtement je
suis pas sûr que ce soit ça donc
ça commence par
cgg le nom et garazi mort pour tout cela
reste et
ça commence par
gkn dicter une doctrine
c'est une entreprise stratégique au
regard du kremlin budget illimité
avec comme une influence du kremlin très
très très forte alors on dira mais rt
fait pas de temps de y'a pas tant de
fausses informations que ça
il y en a une en a eu pour tout ni lu
certains noms et puis non mais il ya des
trucs en fait le problème c'est qu est
ce que vous appelez d'information moi
j'ai vu parfois des papiers où vous
dites vous avez on vous dit par exemple
quand vous mettez dans un site
le professeur duchmol professeur à
l'université dit que
je lis un exemple mais j'ai oublié un
truc est due à vraiment une énormité
au sens strict c'est vrai que duchmol a
dit souffrir mais bon vous pouvez
manipuler avec ce genre de truc et ça on
voit assez fréquemment des conditionnels
des trucs ou en balance du gros comme en
france non je crois pas non moins une
deuxième chose deuxième chose quel que
soit le reproche qu'on puisse le
prochain abondamment par les complices
grands médias français
c'est une affaire sur macron vous la
verrez sur france 24 sur l'audiovisuel
extérieur français les affaires sur
poutine donc en fait ce qui est
important quand on critique il ya
critiqué ce qu'on voit il ya aussi
critiqué ce qu'on ne voit pas c'est à
dire ce qu'il n'apparaît pas et ça c'est
aussi ce qu'il ya en creux et ça c'est
aussi important
en france qu'ils soient pas accrédité à
l'elysée c'est normal
non ils devraient ils devraient l'être
mais il se trouve que ces médias russes
son nom il devrait l'être mais je l'aimé
c'est vrai qu'on est entre la jambe
enfin rtc un truc donc non j'ai vu vous
avez invité sénat fedorova nous il nous
arrivait de moi je veux le rencontrer en
jeu voire jeu mais je dois vous dire
quand je vais je lui ai parlé quand j'ai
rencontré je vais parler de
l'indépendance éditoriale et en français
ou en anglais en anglais
je vais parler de l'indépendance et les
toits voilà elle par exemple nous on a
un truc c'est qu'on c'est un combat
qu'on avait mené au monde i télé c'est
le patron commercial ne doit pas être le
patron de la rédaction
m'alerter s'illusionner et donc et en
l'occurrence
il n'y aura jamais une critique de
poutine c'est comme des chênes conquis
sont aussi il faut dire dans une logique
d'aller voir tout ce qui va pas pour
dans une logique de déstabilisation je
pense qu'il faut ligne d'hier et en même
temps je le dis
c'est
[Musique]
moi je suis pas
c'est vrai qu'à une forme d'
américanisation des vases
américanisation
les états unis à cause de l'histoire
pour deux raisons en partie et
légitimant une influence très forte chez
nous et que parfois on a même plus de
papier sur les élections américaines que
sur les élections européennes qui sont
nos élections les journalistes de france
2 sont incités à plus parler d'europe
comme ça j'en sais rien
mais moi je suis pour qu'on parle plus
d'europe j'ai écrit un bouquin là dessus
enfin là dessus qu'ils étaient un
bouquin sur la gouvernance mondiale et
l'union européenne de la capture de
garches et du pouvoir etc et aujourd'hui
il s'appelait circus politique us pour
qu'on l'a appelée circus politique us
parce que ya une forme de deux théâtres
ou
ne pas parler d'europe pour un jour
alors j'ai pas dit faire de la
propagande pour la gauche pour l'union
européenne
en revanche une partie des décisions
quoi
c'est vachement bien tout d'après ce
dernier c'est fini ce temps là où ça
continue un peu je pense que l'europe
c'est un sujet qui doit être traité
comme les autres
d'ailleur ça rendra aussi service à
l'europe que hélas très marqué
je peux l'aspect
il n'y a pas de raison contre pas de la
même manière et donc des parcs
qu'on a fait on a fait des
investigations sur l'union européenne il
faut le faire et il faut qu'ils aient du
débat de la confrontation je dirai à la
limite
là je m'adresse aux pro européen
l'europe sera beaucoup plus intéressante
quand on quand tu auras du débat une
critique
et et honnêtement pourquoi le catéchisme
qu'elle qui a failli ce n'est pas
attention aux contres le catéchisme et
les
bombes à voilà on a compris ce que je
voulais dire mais le le fait de servir
un discours un peu niveau que ça sert
pas pourquoi pourquoi les médias alors
nous regarde très critique parce qu'on
essaye de les lire pratiquement tous on
n'a pas trop parlé des plateformes oui
mais ça qui est pour moi sans le danger
majeur aujourd'hui on garde le meilleur
pour la fin car d'accord
on regarde ce qui se passe sur internet
on a une communauté qui est très
bienveillante et les lilas son cerveau
ils mettent leur cerveau en séries avec
le nôtre ce qui nous permet de voir des
trucs de d'eddy mitchell a embarqué avec
les gens qui sont anti européen contre
l'europe tout de suite ils sont traités
comme des hérétiques ils sont soit
psychiatrisés ils soient traités comme
des hérétiques soit d'être traités comme
des poux dangereux c'est normal ça c'est
pas normal alors qu'ils aient tort ou
qu'ils aient raison comment ça se fait
que le journalisme en france sur les
entiers aux européens tout de suite il
ya c'est un journalisme d'opinion
non mais c'est pas normal vidéo enfin
moi j'écris la tumeur
je me souviens
c'était c'était prendre à rebrousse poil
ça fait partie des des
jeux prend au plus bas de mai mais si on
veut
que l'europe soit considéré comme
démocratique faut qu'ils aient
d'abord la démocratie c'est quand même
la transparence sur les décisions etc et
la transparence de l'union elle-même
elle s'est améliorée mais le poème si on
regarde pas en fait leur transparence
mais
et qui sert pas à grand chose et donc
faut que ces sujets là
j'ai quand même un moment il faudra je
le développe si je veux dire pourquoi
les journalistes ne font pas parce que
ça n'intéresse pas les gens et c'est là
qu'on aime et on est très souvent dans
un serpent qui se mord la queue en
christophe deloire personnes ont rien à
[__] bardon christophe deloire non
merci oui bah quel courage
qu'est-ce qu'on se déchire
mais
la sociologue pardon bientôt peut-être à
un moment parce que tournier depuis
combien de temps la 35 minute ah non
c'est de la torture c'est de la
manipulation mentale tu veux
comme jamais encore
on est depuis combien ils économisent en
douceur déjà deux heures bon on n'est
qu'à la moitié non
parce que quand on prend la voiture on
va pas être gibelin donc on risque
d'être un peu
on est et où
on était sur quoi j'ai fait ma petite
pause là
un commentaire internet je prends la
première lie à 460 nouveaux messages si
en russie ont fait la même répression
que celle sur les leviers les jaunes en
france il serait le premier ouvert sa
bouche
mais en russie je vous racontais la
situation des journalistes au rôti
russie et les 100 49e au classement
mondial la liberté de la presse la
français les 34 gains de 404 me suicider
en russie c'est ça il ya des suicidés
il ya des tués par exemple de son poney
depuis 2000 c'est à dire depuis
l'arrivée de poutine au pouvoir il ya
trente sept journalistes assassinés
à novaïa gazeta uz six collaborateurs je
crois
des lois ont été passées qui font que
c'est des lois sur la souveraineté
nationale alors là il y en a une plus
récente qu'une loi sur les agents de
l'étranger les jeux avant c'était les
ong là il ya de plus 5 6 ans une loi
avait été adoptée sur les ong qui peut
être conscient comme agent de l'étranger
là les journalistes peuvent être
considérés comme agent de l'étranger
mais la loi est tellement peu clair que
en gros si un copain
étrangers vous fait un cadeau vous
pouvez être vous retrouvez au trou pour
trajan d'étrangers alors c'est une
réponse à une loi sur les agents de
l'étranger américaine généralement les
russes quand ils font de la la mesure de
rétorsion
les russes pendant que j'ai pas les rues
le kremlin
le parallélisme des formes oui
oui il sait qu'il peut provoquer une
forme de montée aux extrêmes
il ya
[Musique]
quasiment plus de médias indépendants
en gros il y avait quelques journaux il
reste une radio echo de moscou la snober
yagg est un état où il ya des gens avec
un courage des monts je pense l'ena
milachina
qui s'est fait tabasser qu'enquête
encore en tchétchénie qui se fait
menacer de mort par
de manière régulière système menacé par
ramzan kadyrov le président tchétchène
s'énerve et disons
il ya une chaîne qui s'appelle doj est
par exemple y avait une chaîne privée
c'est une super chaîne josh et bien on
leur a enlevé les satellites et donc
vous avez ça il ya des laboratoires la
turquie est un laboratoire la russie en
est vous avez toutes sortes de lois
différentes et qui font qu'à un moment
vous tapez fiscalement vous tapez
[Musique]
enfin on trouve plein de moyens de vous
réduire et alors qu'elle n'a pas été
totalement supprimées comme ça ça existe
on peut dire regardez du public sur des
chaises mais mais vous en avez voilà
aujourd'hui
quelques-uns vous avez cette journaliste
en taule aujourd'hui en russie
bref
j'ai pas les noms de tous mais là il y
en a une qui est sorti mais qui a été
condamné à petit ça veut dire être un
âpre au copier va
elle c'était pour
l'avait accusé en fait on vous accuse de
terrorisme d'apologie du terrorisme
d'atteinte à la souveraineté nationale à
une nouvelle loi sur le respect des
autorités face à
la répression la cdu
s'est dit certain que
la loi sur la sédition
puissent les dix yeux est ce que est ce
qu'on va pouvoir accuser quelqu'un
maintenant en france pour le discréditer
comme il faut en russie alors je vois
pas exactement c'est dans la levée d'un
genou en fait très peur en nombre
aux questions intérieures ya un peu de
ça grince un peu et autres questions
internet en vain prendre 3 2 1
la connivence malsaine entre politiques
et journalistes éthique ou pas
est ce que est ce qu'on peut aller dîner
ou siècle quand on est journaliste
c'est quoi le siècle le siècle j'ai
aussi écrit sur le siècle dans un
bouquin donc c'est un sujet voilà
on est gentil c'est un club
qui se réunit dans le 8e arrondissement
de paris où il ya des grands patrons
quelques journalistes des politiques
s'appelle le dîner du siècle
ça a été créée je crois après la seconde
guerre mondiale
et c'est des endroits où des gens de
pouvoir se rencontrent
l'enjeu pour les journalistes moi je
pense que journaliste il faut toujours
garder sa forme de liberté par exemple
je pense que je pense que il faut pas
être exactement comme son interlocuteur
et qu'on est beaucoup plus libre quand
on n'est pas exactement comme son
interlocuteur
mais l'enjeu c'est quand même le
journalisme c'est une science enfin
c'est pas une science mais celles de
manière métaphorique dans mes de la
sciotte de la proximité
et et
de l'éloignement c'est à dire que vous
soyez quand même assez proche des
sources d'information que c'est bien
joli mais ce n'est pas en restant chez
soi qu'on a les infos c'est quand même
en allant voir des gens donc faut
arriver à les rencontrer
les infiltrés pas se laisser les
recruter tout l'enjeu
mais
moi je préfère quand même non mais moi
je préfère des journalistes
évidemment que ça arrive enfin le
syndrome de stockholm ça existe ça c'est
pour les otages
dans les années 70 les policiers
d'extrême droite qui infiltraient les
groupes trotskistes finissait par être
trotskiste donc quand on arrive dans un
milieu toujours
mais je pense que le journalisme ça doit
être la liberté sociale ça doit être
d'aller dans des milieux sociaux des des
lieux mais aussi des milieux différents
et et de garder sa distance mais ça
suppose que vous rencontriez les gens
moi j'aimerais pas des journalistes
qu'ils restent chez eux tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs voilà qu'il s'agisse pour des
deux guerres de politique de n'importe
quoi fallait voir les gens dont on va
parler il faut aller voir les gens qui
pensent le contraire aussi et puis il
faut aller voir il faut enquêter et puis
mes mais je pense faut pas reprocher des
journalistes d'aller voir mais voilà moi
je suis pas je suppose qu'avec le
chutant aucun top comme ça et je pense
que n'importe
quoi
pourtant quand
on arrive aux plateformes
une petite question internet d'exhaustif
quels sont les liens de l'est restait à
faire et robert ménard que pense-t-il du
travail qu'il avait effectué alors
robert ménard quitté l'organisation en
il n'exerce plus aucune fonction depuis
il était juste rester
président d'honneur et à un moment il a
plus été si on était pris ce qui le
serait plus
donc toute sa trajectoire d'après salut
à partir ça n'est pas l'histoire ménard
a dirigé l'organisation pendant 23 ans
il a fait partie des quatre fondateurs
en fait à l'origine un simple n'a pas
été créée à paris mais a été créée à
montpellier par quatre journalistes dont
robert ménard de radio france héros qui
voulaient faire des reportages dans les
pays dont les médias dominants ne
parlait pas
ça n'a pas
super marché donc qui sont mis à la
défendent la liberté de la presse et
ménard avait un
talent de l'absence de la provocation
qui n'a pas perdu qui n'est pas votre
cas
en fait ça n'est pas que des questions
de personnes et ça n'est pas la même
époque
à vous allez manger devant moi ça c'est
encore plus de la torture
donc bon spécial journalistes adacore
banon mais je voudrais permettre les
mains si en période de kovy d'en
apprendre mais aussi on reprochera 2 et
donc c'est un d'origine non mais on
était alors pour dire l'évolution et est
rien cette fois on a changé mais on a
changé parce que
l'idéal c'est défendre le droit à
l'information mais on peut plus faire
comme avant
je vous explique les rapports
géopolitiques ont changé
à l'époque où rsf est créé en fait
l'idée c'est de faire parler dans les
médias occidentaux
notamment des situations de violations
de la liberté de la presse dans des pays
dans des régimes autoritaires et
notamment dans le tiers-monde et
d'exercer une pression
par le média
aujourd'hui
si on ne fait que ça e on peut aller
balancer de lancre sur des ambassades
etc
mais si on le fait
si on pense que cette stratégie du
naming and shaming dénoncer et faire
honte
suffit c'est faux en fait et c'était moi
je sais c'est à dire qu'on dit et qu'on
veut augmenter parce que dans toute
l'équipe a tout les toute notre équipe
qui est confronté c'est à dire
il ya des moments où si vous ne faites
que ça
vous prenez le risque que la personne
reste plus de temps en taule ça m'est
arrivé que des gens
représentants des régimes autoritaires
10 si vous faites ça il passera plus de
temps en taule alors on peut se dire
mais c'est un faux
c'est une fausse allégation mais
n'empêche que parfois c'est vrai donc il
faut qu'on n'ose est ce qu'on fait c'est
que nous on n'est pas là pour faire de
la provocation pour la provocation on
n'est pas là pour faire plaisir à
prendre des poses de bellâtre ou de
moraliste dans les beaux quartiers
on est là pour obtenir des résultats et
les résultats ça s'obtient pas ce que
vous arrivez à dénoncer subtilement à
tenir les mots qui conviennent au bon
moment subtilement ouf mais la subtilité
peut être dur et en même temps à parler
à porter des argumentaires à négocier à
trouver toutes sortes de bill est allé
chercher des proxys des gens qui
pourront exercer leur influence
bref c'est si je puis dire un arsenal
parce que donald mais c'est une gamme
d'activités beaucoup plus large et est
donc donc on a évolué là dessus pour
pour être
dans voilà une éthique faits
dont l'objet est d'obtenir des résultats
et donc donc tout n'est pas eu le plus
efficace n'est pas toujours le plus
visible ça je sais que c'est donc en
fait c'est normal vous êtes jugés sur le
visible parce que les gens ils
ce qu'ils voient mais la réalité une
vraie c'est un peu d'arguments des
services des enseignants pour justifier
leurs actions
on n'est pas contre ça qu'on a déjà
arrêté là mais évidemment que vous
pouvez faire la propagande sur
l'invisible je vais l'avocat du diable
évidemment pour le faire c'est parce
qu'il estime à internet et après moi là
dessus
venez voir comment ça fonctionne et est
déjà
question internet la couverture des
conflits de l'ex-yougoslavie à la syrie
était irréprochable selon lui
non mais rien moi je dirais jamais que
quelqu'un est irréprochable la
couverture est irréprochable de voir la
couverture et les multiples là je vais
être obligé de poser c'est pour une
question mais c'est un commentaire mais
qui est fait en majuscules et quand
c'est donald trump qui nous écrit je
vous n'êtes pas des majuscules
vous êtes payés par les cia qui sur
internet
ça n'être que je répondrais oui
non non
vous avez des preuves de ça
alors c'est plus facile de faire des
preuves de culpabilité que des preuves
d'innocence c'est le grand truc c'est
que l'innocence des journalistes bon le
grand truc des journalistes et la
culpabilité par un amalgame ça c'est
magnifique ça peut arriver c
est
dur de ne s'en pose pas robert ménard a
déjà vu
à part une pétition pour libérer julian
assange il a fait quoi ils ont fait quoi
vouloir ajouter quelques mots
on a
parlé dans les médias du monde entier
londres avec la mitchell est intervenu
youtube partout porter cette parole là
et ça l afem aider on en a fait à paris
on a fait dans tous les bureaux on a
dans le monde
on est intervenu pour lui on a
voyez il ya une grande conférence sur la
liberté de la presse à londres qui est
organisée il ya deux étés
le gouvernement britannique en fait
c'était un truc diplomatiques notamment
du bric site a lancé une grande
coalition de 30 états sur la liberté de
la presse yves et jeremy hunt ministre
britannique j'étais le seul à parler
d'un seul jeu devant lui donc il ya
quand même porté auprès d'eux par
l'intermédiaire des médias et de manière
directe
le discours
en fait ce qu'on fait peser ces voix là
ça sera la honte pour vous s'il vous
l'extrader
question internet qui pas une question
oui c'est un peu pour ça de votre gueule
il pourra nous dire si gaspard gonce
devient un mécène de rsf est-ce qu'il
sera soutenu
on ne fait pour n'est pas une ong qu'une
activité censitaire
vous parlez de temps au temps des
bavures des américains
s'il ya des journalistes qui sont mettre
en taule aux états unis des moyens de
pression ont viré par les rédactions
souffrons plus souvent quand même
réussir un gros truc aux états unis
quel est le changement et on y avait
activement contribué de la doctrine
américaine en matière d'otages parce
qu'en fait vous savez ce que james foley
ce journaliste qui a été décapité
on a beaucoup travaillé que sa mère
diane foley est en fait les
contrats m d'autres parents d'otages
américains thaïs
supposé toujours vivant en syrie
y avait un moment où la doctrine
américaine en matière d'otages c'était
ça n'est que la sphère
des familles des rédactions et des
assureurs nous est à mon sens
alors c'est encore pire au japon ou si
vous vous faites prendre des otages ou
fait conspuer par
l'opinion
et est donc
le fbi qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient il
allait voir les parents et c'est arrivé
il disait si vous versez 1 dollars
de rançon vous serez condamné pour
financement du terrorisme
et diane folle elle s'est retrouvée à
échanger des e-mails avec existe
vous imaginez la solitude dans une
détresse et
obama a accepté après la mort de foley
on a on a plaidé a ré ouvert un dossier
il ya eu
six mois de discussions nous la
directrice notre bureau aux états unis
elle a eu dix réunions avec le national
security council la maison blanche est
vieille et puis a eu un changement
annoncé par obama
de la doctrine américaine est maintenant
le bail par exemple aide et de ce point
de vue là je dois dire qu'en france quoi
qu'on
l'appareil d'état aide quand il ya des
otages
c'est pas une question c'est un
commentaire et je veux dire quand même
leur compte sur leur site c'est aussi
faux que sa parole il y a des lignes
mécénat 22% en 2019 qui nous détaille
rien du tout
c'est s'aider mécénat c'est des
individus qui donne de l'argent j'en ai
j'ai cité le principal tout à l'heure
par exemple à celui qui en 2010 ont fait
cela va donner le plus on passe aux
plateformes
qu'un président en exercice se fasse
censuré même s'il racontait importe de
coin qu'il appelait la violence ou pas
la violence si des historiens qui nous
la synthèse ça pose quel type de
problème la souveraineté numérique
européenne la souveraineté numérique
française d'après soyons fous
les plateformes devient devienne un
danger ou il en oui les journalistes qui
participent à la modération sur ces
plateformes sont là pour cautionner pas
cautionner essayer d'améliorer les
choses 5 points beaucoup de questions
mais alors la première c'est que c'est
vertigineux
et un danger qui peut être funeste que
des plateformes
censure
président élu ou non qui
donc ce soit des entreprises privées qui
prennent ce type de décision
après avoir
et je suis pas du tout en train de
justifier l'ensemble des insanités et
des
fausses informations diffusées par trump
sur ces réseaux donc ça pose une
question générale et où là il faut pas
qu'on soit dans la critique faut qu'on
soit dans la solution et et c'est une
chose sur laquelle on a beaucoup
travaillé et réservé qu'est ce qui s'est
passé
jusqu'à présent et je reviens à propos
que j'ai on a eu tout à fait au début
jusqu'à présent c'étaient les parlements
qui édicte
les règles de la libération public
quels sont les types de leurs actuels
que parce que c'est en fait c'est un
sujet très compliqué et où
on peut s'attacher à avoir simplement
les phénomènes l'augmentation de la
propagande et des opérations de
déstabilisation et notamment d'état
étrangers ce truc l'inflammation des
propos de haine etc ça c'est des
phénomènes ça n'est pas nouveau ça a
toujours existé ce qui est nouveau c'est
que le système ce qu'on appelait le
système de l'espace public c'est à dire
l'organisation l'infrastructure elle
favorise sa
les algorithmes et une enquête du hem
haïti qui prouve que les fausses
informations un potentiel viral six fois
supérieure au vrai
ça ça peut nous emporter ça peut nous
mener vers la guerre civile
parce que ce qui surgit aujourd'hui
c'est juste
l'énervement de chacun dans sa bulle et
la détestation d'autrui les line
acceptation de la parole d'autrui et
puis surtout le
l'emportement sur lequel genre de choses
non vérifiés et démocratie ça toujours
l'or a été l'organisation de la
délibération démocratie c'est des
procédures au fond téléprocédures sur le
pouvoir et ses des procédures sur la
libération il ya deux types de
procédures il y en a sur un
seront peuplés de la régulation de
contenu c'est comment les contenus qui
font exception à la liberté d'expression
sont pas ceux qui les portons
confrontent leurs responsabilités et
c'est beau
la déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
qui a été traduite je veux uniquement
par le pacte relatif aux droits civils
et politiques prévoit des exceptions
légitime à la liberté d'expression qu'on
trouve mal définis mais prévoit des
observations enfin du tout un travail
juridique etc et il ya comme en ondes et
on évacue de contenus là
et comment on n'évacue pas trop c'est à
dire comment alain verts sont sur ce
temps sur pas
et ça le prend aujourd'hui ceux qui
prennent ces décisions avant c'était les
juges
maintenant c'est les plateformes et ces
mamelles qui disent qu'est-ce qui peut
être évacuées ou pas qui font leur choix
bref c'est le capital loi mais non
seulement c'est le capitanat c'est elle
qui les dictent
puisque avance que le parlement a adopté
comme la maintenance et les
conditions générales d'utilisation cgu
donc elles ont remplacé les parlements
elles ont remplacé les appareils
judiciaires et elles ont même remplacé
les organes de régulation façon conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel c'est elle
qui organise le champ médiatique parce
que dans toutes les démocraties alors
tout le monde dans le débat public et
sur cette question qui est fondamentale
de caisse qui est dans le champ du
licite et qu'est ce qui est fait
exception en droit international on dit
restrictions raisonnable la liberté
d'expression mais il ya un autre aspect
dans toutes les démocraties c'est que
dans tout ce qui est autorisé et le
mensonge
n'est pas interdite sauf dans un champ
spécifique par exemple aura français
qu'est la vie économique
mais de manière générale vous avez droit
de mentir aux abords de faire des
publicités vous allez m'aider des règles
ont été posées par
c'est ce qu'on appelle la régulation des
médias pour favori garantir le
pluralisme pour
favoriser la fiabilité de l'information
sur l'indépendance et c est ça ça
complètement volé en éclats donc ceux
qui aujourd'hui critique que les gens à
juste titre tout ça dans les médias ne
voit pas que au fond dans le reste de
l'espace public bien aucune
l'indépendance ce
trial garantie du tout et la fiabilité
le pluralisme
bref on a donné les clés de nos
démocraties
aux plateformes numériques on l'a fait
en tant que consommateur et de
consommateurs qui ont été compacts
compris ce qui se passait
historiquement on a dit les plateformes
elles doivent être neutres enfin elles
doivent être pardon irresponsable et
c'était bien vu à l'époque c'est à dire
on avait ces nouveaux tuyaux et si on
donnait la responsabilité aux
plateformes de dire
de sélectionner le contenu c'était
extrêmement bon jour on a dit elle sont
irresponsables dans les pas de la
neutralité du net la balle hors cc liée
à la neutralité du net c'est aussi sur
la quantité d'informations le banc de
passe
mais en fait il ya plusieurs types de
neutralité il yad'autres alité en termes
d'accès aux services et puis une
neutralité qui est est ce que le tuyau
est heureusement le tuyau il doit jamais
faire de choix éditoriaux qui non c'est
l'ouverture à l'arbitraire le plus total
et la dictature dictature et
éventuellement par une entreprise près
et mais les plateformes maintenant elles
se sont mises à faire autre chose elle
trie l'information
les algorithmes décide de ce convoi est
ce qu'on voit pas de ce qu'on voit en
premier de ce qu'on voit en deuxième de
ce qu'on voit moins
et on n'a aucune garantie par exemple si
mark zuckerberg veut changer son
algorithme et favoriser un camp
politique le peut aujourd'hui les
protéger par sa liberté d'expression
nous en tant qu démocratie on lui a pas
dit il ya une règle tant algorithmes il
doit être neutre politiquement
idéologiquement
religieusement etc non mais c'est pas
c'est pas
vous avez derrière faire ça non non
c'est pas du violon c'est un vrai truc
enfin imaginons que l'influent tout si
nous sommes énormes et on alors on passe
notre temps là sur les médias français
il ya eu des mesures anti concentration
sur les médias français alors surtout
aller aux gars en tout ça il ya toujours
des dispositions et le mec qu'a 2
milliards 500 millions peut-être 3
milliards maintenant de compte lui il
fait ce qu'il veut
en fait faux le problème là le gros
problème c'est le mec à 3 milliards deux
équipes qui aujourd'hui fait ce qu'il
veut
les lois de barques de ggp a une
obsession sur mark zuckerberg
parce que lui même il a subi d'une
certaine manière son pouvoir enfin il
lui a été donné par le par l'évolution
technologique et parce qu'il a fait
c'est pas il n'a pas fait de coup d'état
mais ces lois ne sont pas transparentes
il n'est pas obligé voyez à la
libération il ya une loi qui a adopté en
france s'appelle la loi bichet alors
peut-être que pas grand monde ne connaît
la loi bichet vient juste d'être rénovée
la loi bichet c'est la loi qui garantit
le pluralisme de la distribution de la
presse écrite en gros maintenant je suis
le la distribution elle est aujourd'hui
le distributeur le celui qui emmène dans
les entrepôts
celui qui le kiosquier ou le marchand de
journaux parce que le plupart des
marchands de journaux ne sont pas que ce
qui est ça c'est très parisien
il peut pas choisir il devait dire ah
non mais moi je dis ce but que les gens
d'autres dont on a tous moi que ceux du
centre ou moins que ceux de gauche il
doit tout distribuer il n'y a pas de
deux et vous et d'extrême gauche
d'extrême droite de trucs vous trouvez
dans le kiosque
cette garantie l'a77 loi l'équivalent de
la loi bichet aujourd'hui
la décision sur la distribution de
l'information sur le numérique c'est les
patrons des plateformes qui les prennent
donc intérêts privés pour les
plateformes américaines
intérêts politiques pour les plateformes
chinoise
on
pense alors laissé en france c'est
l'intérêt
mais non mais en france le sait les
plateformes américaines surtout enfin
et il n'y a pas de plateforme enfin la
moteur de recherche compte mais qui pas
dans la même course
et dont un instant
kokou koffigoh
alors moi une règle c'était toujours ma
première phrase au sein de formation de
juriste ne dit jamais ce qui va se
passer demain vous n'en savez rien alors
la nia long terme c'est intéressant
fabrizio le futur mais pas sous l'angle
de avec des certitudes
et est donc
bon petit faucon
il faut qu'on réfléchisse à que c'est
quoi leur obligation comme elles doivent
travailler quelles institutions
démocratiques pour en traiter et c'est
un travail qu'on a lancé
avec une commission qu'on appelait
commission d'information démocratie avec
des
nobel des des grands spécialistes de
nouvelles technologies j'ai vraiment des
grands grands noms des spécialités des
journalistes en proie à des régimes
autoritaires
et on a obtenu et on a même droit de
suite et terra consigne un partenariat
sur l'information la démocratie sur la
base de la vision qu'on a édicté
con con alors c'est un texte transpose
aimé qu'on ce texte pour l'instant c'est
du droit de non contraignant on a amené
quand même 38 démocratie à à soutenir ce
cette vision après on a créé un organe
qui s'appelle le forum sur la formation
adéquate pratique est purement société
civile pour faire de la vraie
recommandations parce qu'en fait la
question sur ces questions c'est plus de
se dire faut-il donner des
responsabilités aux plateformes la
réponse est oui la question c'est
lesquels comment et là notre forum sur
la formation la démocratie qu'on a créé
avec 11 signe tant que centre de
recherche de partout dans le monde
pakistan afrique du sud aux états unis
il vient de remettre 250 recommandations
très précises sur certains aspects de la
régulation il n'y a pas tout mais on est
dans un moment où il ya des grandes lois
qui sont dans les tuyaux un peu partout
dans le monde digital services isaac en
europe alors la gloire des aspects
d'ailleurs dans la loi par avance dans
la halle au séparatisme on a appris il
ya quelques jours
'digital schachter au canada chapter
seventy nine en inde sectionne tout
sorti aux états unis c'est le moment de
poser une vision et nous à rsf on s'est
dit
on défend et on met toute notre énergie
à défendre des journalistes qui incarne
nos idéaux
mais faut qu'on s'intéresse à les règles
du aux règles du jeu ne suffit pas de
défendre des joueurs si les règles du
jeu prévoit que les joueurs perdent
c'est pas la peine donc faut travailler
sur l'aspect systémique des choses et
est donc on est une organisation
aujourd'hui qui travaillent à défendre
des journalistes partout dans le monde
des grands des petits des jeunes des
vieux des droites d'être gauche est
partout mais des gens france le dernier
vous avez des frustrés qui met en en
défendant tout le temps aujourd'hui
alors je passe ici est paru si on va le
faire paraître demain ou après demain
mais on défend une journaliste bretonne
si on laisse les pressions du linas
l'hérault de la pression du lobby voilà
et qui fait l'objet d'un nouveau procès
qui risque de faire venir
est une bande dessinée algues vertes
voilà c'est la dernière haie et donc
honnêtement pour une organisation ça
fait du boulot donc oui il ya des
moments franchement voudrais pouvoir
tout faire partout mais le fait le fait
que des journalistes collabore avec les
gars fin pour la modération et moi je
pense que c'est un
il ya des grands médias qui ont passé
des accords
il ya des grands médias compass est d
accord je pense qu'à long terme c'est
c'est un risque très attention il faut
que la cuillère est très longue vous que
le puits reste très bien ces images non
c'est là je fais référence à
l'expression sûr quand on dîne avec le
diable il faut le faire avec une
connaissez le proverbe louvière mais ces
programmes africains avec le diable non
non
quand tu te couches avec le diable quand
tu te réveille le lendemain matin tu
sens encore le diable
c'est joli c'est un proverbe que j'ai
appris avec des touareg
qui avait qui avait signé les accords
avec al-qaïda dans le coin et les
africains du sud y lisent et mon pote tu
as signé avec al-qaïda t'inquiète pas
que demain matin tu vas encore sentir le
diable donc gdg détails donc
les journalistes qui travaillent avec
les gaffes un fou une cuillère
suffisamment longue
alors le genre n'existerait pas de
directement pour les gaffes a cédé
médias qui font des partenariats
notamment sur des des classes du
partenariat qui touchent l'argent des
médias mais parce qu'on se retrouve en
fait qu'il faut il faut recréer un
écosystème de l'information ah bah on a
un écosystème enfin qui détruit
exemple c'est un peu l'équivalent de la
commission
comment non mais mais pas
mais j'espère que j'aurai au moins
réussi à faire passer cette idée si on
est on peut avoir du sens à ce qu'on
peut avoir d'abord
aux nettement l'idée selon laquelle elle
tout ce qu'on vous raconterai serait
faux etc je me
déshabille
c'est oui à des erreurs oui même les
plus grands peuvent faire des erreurs la
question c'est est-ce que
globalement on peut faire confiance
comment on élargit le pluralisme
commandez vite aujourd'hui de se
retrouver avec cet espace public où
c'est des entreprises privées qui
organise l'ensemble de notre
délibération qui peuvent faire avec ces
avantages puisque jeudi à la commission
questions horizontale ça permet aussi de
sortir de certains certaines formes de
domination
il ya des avantages à ce qui est de la
concurrence et du mois je suis pas
demandeur qui est le filtre
journalistique partout mais comment on
évite un débat où c'est simplement le
plus fort qui gagne et où chacun croit
en étant plus en plus isolé qui comprend
mieux en mieux les choses alors qu'en
fait il est plus en plus isolé que le
cas échéant il s'en prendra plus sur la
gueule de la part d'un pouvoir ou d'un
ami et finalement ce système il en train
de monter tous contre tous et et
regardons
il y avait trois démocraties en 1790 il
xi
a alors la première mais en 1790 je
connais pas c'est l'histoire d'haïti
pour sorciers à ce moment là mais mais
il y en avait
le nombre de démocraties après la
seconde guerre mondiale a été multiplié
par 4 jusqu'à 2000 et après la
conférence est et on a notre théorie par
rapport à cela alors y'a puis
consommation énergétique puis à des
démocraties puis la liberté -
consommation énergétique plus à ce point
c'est une thèse vraiment intéressante ça
marche aussi avec le terrorisme
mais il ya qualité du journalisme aussi
il ya aussi le fait est en fait oui
voilà et le débat public là est
peut-être le point essentiel l'enjeu
on peut critiquer c'est très bien on
peut se complaire dans la critique on a
le droit c'est pas nécessairement utile
la question c'est comment on fait
et cette question là elle mérite d'être
discutée
est-ce que vous pensez que la profession
a suffisamment de conduite introspective
une résilience suffisamment importante
pour avoir ce type d'attitude saurait
omettre en question en fait je pense que
les journalistes parce que les
autocritiques beaucoup nos notes je joue
une boucle ça a échoué à l'ephec news on
est passé d'un mais même sur le même
mode portrait dans une rédaction vous
pouvez voir tout le monde qui critique
tout le monde ou l'autre médias les gens
ce qui est une volonté la question c'est
arrivé à repenser mais c'est pas qu'à
cause de journalisme je pense que la
question du journaliste note l'action du
journalisme n'est pas que la sphère des
journalistes enfin abbas est en arrêt
marquis non mais ça doit pas l'être donc
le besoin l affaire de tous enfin
mais c'est notre affaire alors là entre
il ya des enjeux pour la communauté
nationale il ya des enjeux pour la
communauté humaine d enjeu qui dépasse
le cadre national
on a besoin d'information fiable avec
une égalité dans l'accès à l'information
des visions du monde différentes mais
sur des bases factuelles sérieuse
et ça on en
on en a
sinon comment va lutter contre
les intégrations la dégradation
environnementale et de la biodiversité
la corruption les discriminations les
inégalités tout ça on a besoin de
ça et c'est là martias scène qui disait
que dans les pays où il ya une liberté
d'information il n'ya pas de famine il
n'ya pas de famine n'ya pas de famine le
grand
c'est un indien enfin américain
d'origine indienne et de la famine en
france
il ya des gens sous alimentés qu'on a du
mal à s'alimenter de la famille les
étudiants les étudiants non nommés de la
famille oui ou non c'est pas à spalletti
pis c'est pas l'ethiopie des années de
famille commentaire mais comment taire
mais oui pardon les plateformes fond ce
que les journaux n'ont toujours fait
orienter l'opinion
mais il ya mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut
répondre à cette personne mais jusque
hommes
les journaux en avoir à les acheter
l'uma valeurs actuelles le figaro le
monde libé autre chose heureusement il
ya des nouveaux il ya une réinvention de
journalisme aujourd'hui dont on n'a pas
parlé c'est pas des sites disclose chez
que vous avez bien vu je cite pas à
dessein parce que c'est formidable ce
qu'ils font des clauses c'est formidable
parce qu'ils font
des gens qui réinvente le journalisme
avec la bande dessinée
d'autres qui font du grand reportage
longue durée il ya des journalistes dans
des journalistes expérimentés qui font
ça à des tout jeunes enfin il ya ça ça
bouillonne heureusement communautaire
d'internet c'est quoi la différence
entre les plateformes et le tri d'un
format qui trie d'information et rsf qui
trient les journalistes
est-ce qu'on peut répondre à cette
personne au pas grand chose franchement
on trie pas les journalistes on est
dans un régime de moyens limités on
défend autant que possible tout ce qu'on
peut et mais les plateformes et puis
jour où rsf on aura 2 milliards 500
millions de gens qui enfin
on aura la capacité de
2,2 connaître les moindres goût de de
surveiller de faire les choix sans que
ces règles soient transparentes à rsf
sa mère et racon soit très limité mais
juste je disais hommes
ça n'est pas l'équivalent d'un média
c'est une erreur très très grave je
pense enfin de penser qu'une plateforme
c'est comme un média la plateforme c'est
ça peut être en partie un média jégou
mais si vous
êtes totalement nouvelle manière je
pense aux assistants personnels qui font
des réponses unique c'est bon pour
l'instant vous pouvez pas dire poser des
questions petite politique générale vous
posez des questions sur quel temps mathy
faire demain mais comment la formation
est produite ça vous n'avez aucune
visibilité les médias vous aurez quand
même plus
c'est le réseau de distribution non
menaces de visibilité avec les médias
bah quand même oui
la plateforme numérique oui les médias
la régulation des médias vous allez voir
qu'elle est la loi comment ça fonctionne
les médias vous avez des règles savez
comment ça fonctionne dans les médias
quand quelqu'un
fait une infraction une règle bon alors
retrouvé plein il ya des gens qui
gueulent il ya des gens qui se
surveillent dents mais toi tu dois enfin
il ya des procédures qui ont été
instaurées démocratiquement qui sont pas
parfaites mais l'idée selon laquelle il
faudrait que le monde soit parfait pour
que
il faut aller vers le mieux nous on se
bat pour ça mais mais
mais
mais la question c'est d'arriver au
mieux ces s'est pas voilé on est dans
une société humaine ya pas de perfection
les plateformes c'est des boîtes noires
ces algorithmes franchement et les
boîtes noires il ya que les développeurs
ont dit le code qu'au 10 lots le quad
c'est la loi langage de poèmes mais
c'est vrai le code c'est la loi et ses
lois c'est pas nos démocraties donc moi
à la fin nos démocraties elles sont
imparfaites nos démocraties il faut
faire attention faut être vigilant etc
je préfère quand même les institutions
démocratiques dans les pays
démocratiques à
des intérêts privés et puis les médias
il ya des lois anti concentration
il ya des obligations s'est pas
lassé les plateformes
c'est la place du village je vais
revenir à des choses très basiques c'est
l'organisation
la place du village c'est l'endroit où
on discute
cette place elle doit
la décision qui est prise sur comment on
discute elle l'a toujours été enfin dans
les démocraties établies
démocratiquement c'est là et c'est cet
immense changement ou maintenant c'est
plus le cas et où ça ça peut nous
emporter vous connaissez la célèbre
phrase de grands philosophes
hoolywoodien denzel washington je vais
vous les lire si vous lisez pas si vous
lisez pas les journaux vous n'êtes pas
informés si vous lisez les journaux vous
êtes mal informé
que ce qu'est ce que vous en pensez non
mais le côté enfin
l'information d'étymologie c'est ça
vient de forme c'est mettre en forme
et donc c'est donner des représentations
du réel
et les représentations du réel même sur
des bases factuelles solides elles
peuvent être très diverses
parce que même avec des faits tous vrai
bon on peut voir le monde de manière
différente la question c'est que on est
quand même puis s'appuyer sur des
réalités vérité factuelle et d'une
phrase que puisque c'étaient des grands
philosophes moi aussi je veux citer la
mienne hannah arendt
qui dans la chine je m'attendais pujadas
mais les baffes ses engouements deux
niveaux qui dit la liberté d'opinion est
une farce si l'information sur les faits
n'est pas garantie et si ce ne sont pas
les faits eux mêmes qui font l'objet du
débat et ce à un fun et puis ne puisse
jamais le réel
une multiplicité de freiner puis jamais
le réel mais en tout cas ça nous permet
de parler sur des bases solides et et
c'est ça qu'il faut retrouver c'est ça
qu'il faut développer question internet
est ce que vous êtes contre l'anonymat
sur internet
alors
l'anonymat
et notre commission sur la formation
démocratie a dit que l'anonymat de
devait être l'exception
et il peut y avoir des exceptions
légitime mais le principe est plutôt
qu'on sache qui parle
c'est à dire que si moi je suis
révolutionner en egypte non alors dans
le régime d exception c'est exactement
pour ça mais on en a travaillé avec des
gens gens restent sûrs que philippe un
russe français
alors dans la commission il y avait une
grande juriste mireille delmas marty
mais
j'ai été coprésidée par shirin ebadi la
prix nobel de la paix iranienne
précisément ça fait partie des
exceptions mais les régimes autoritaires
honnêtement il semble qu'ils s'ennuient
pas toutes façons ils savent qui qui
fait quoi et donc donc la question
pardon pour l'est de la france là
non je parle de des régimes autoritaires
au sens fort du terme dans un régime
autoritaire mais soft c'est ça moi il
est plus il est plus la maîtrise si on
attend si on entend par l'egypte moi je
passe mes journées à parler des régimes
autoritaires où on à bastille les gens
on les frappe on les détient longtemps
c'est quoi longtemps aubin avait des
gens en chine ils sont condamnés à 15
ans de taule
quand font des vrais gros enfin qu'en
france ou non mais voyez moi j'ai une
tendresse et beaucoup d'incidents mais
par exemple on s'est beaucoup battu en
turquie la turquie on peut dire c'est
une démocratie et des élections
c'est un pays où
il est des dizaines de journalistes en
tôle où quelques libération là mais non
c'est un peu réduit mais il ya eu des
moyens gens restent sûrs que j'adore
jack dündar qui était le patron
djoumhouria tenir la république en turc
j'étais avec lui au monde peu après sa
libération
vous pouviez pas france traverser une
rue d'istanbul sans que ça prenne 20
minutes tellement c'était une gloire
pour pour des gens d'istanbul
à lui il a dû quitter la turquie sa
femme pour le rejoindre enfin donc il
allait partir en exil
il vient d'être condamné à pas loin de
30 ans de prison ces biens ont été
saisis sa femme qui voulait le rejoindre
mais qu'il était pour rien ses activités
lui il avait que des activités
journalistiques impeccable en mai ils
étaient accusés de terrorisme parce
qu'il avait
publié des vidéos qui démontrait des
livraisons d'armes par les services de
renseignements turcs à des groupes
islamistes du nord de la syrie
sa femme elle a été privée pendant
plusieurs années de le rejoindre on a
retenu son passeport à l'aéroport enfin
c'était une torture j'ai vu des gens
là-bas où monsieur était en détention
pour un tweet d'un journaliste
sa femme qui travaille dans une autre
rédaction avait retweeter le tweet se
retrouver en détention en france on peut
être convoquée par des séries dans les
tweets
oui mais france un journaliste est
content mais alors sur la des séries sur
la des séries à une série de
provocations des notamment des jantes
disclosed et j'ai ici maintenant non
mais c'est déjà ici maintenant
l'ancienne dst
il ya une série de ariane chemin du
monde
le patron du monde si je me souviens
bien pour même papier
nom patronymique je me trompe peut-être
coeur de vous faire sortir sur la france
quand même hein mais non mais non non
on a gueulé là dessus on a gueulé parce
que
c'était une intimidation
mais
juste je parle aussi de ce que je vois
partout dans le monde et juste
j'essaie d'être
mesurés ultra ferme
mais d'avoir une bonne vue des rapports
pour parce que sinon on peut favoriser
le mal on peut favoriser le
l'autoritarisme et la dictature il
s'agit pas pour se faire plaisir de
favoriser ce qui est pire juste c'est
s'inscrire monde est à fond sqr sf qui
critiquent le gouvernement français ça
donne des balles à des régimes beaucoup
plus autorité 1
c'est pour ça que vous en pensez c'est
sûr que quand vous critiquez vraiment
français résume
le gouvernement français
vous vous êtes
repris par les médias turcs
et que vous avez parfois une
instrumentalisation de ces choses là
c'est à dire
où
vous avez des médias de propagande qui
balancent eux mais moi je mets ça ça
vaut partout dans le monde surtout le
truc nous nous par exemple alors cité et
alerter tout à l'heure
sur la turquie bon on attendait pas
leurs questions parce que c'était
uniquement en fonction des intérêts
russes et les questions n'étaient pas
lui-même en fonction des mimes enfin et
nous faut qu'on soit vigilant là dessus
puisque l'objectif c'est enfin nous
c'est dénoncer avec grande fermeté ce
qui doit l'être
pas d'avoir des effets pervers c'est
tout l'enjeu enfin il ya une éthique de
responsabilité à la fin parce que le but
c'est crier fort mais le but ultime
c'est pas de crier fort c'est d'obtenir
des résultats qui vont dans le bon sens
et est donc moi je pense que sur ce que
tout se faire des procès d'intention des
trucs
je suis heureux d'être là pouvoir
exposer aujourd'hui tout ça est de
répondre à celle qui est venue pardon
c'est pour ça que vous aidez moi bien
sûr
parce qu'ici on peut temps libre vous
d'abord parce qu'on peut parler alors
que d'autres endroits où on peut parler
librement et parfois 25 secondes
et la liberté 25 chose que
parce qu'on a parlé longtemps
et aussi parce que
j'ai envie de m'adresser enfin je trouve
ça vraiment très positif de m'adresser à
un public est aussi un public
extrêmement critique et et
je trouve moi j'ai plutôt envie d'aller
discuter avec des gens qui pensent pas
la même chose
qui le cas échéant pense pis que pendre
des journalistes et d'aller
voilà je vous aurais peut-être pas
convaincu mais connaissiez la chaîne
s'est du coup la question vous avez vu
qu'aucune vidéo
j'en ai vu plusieurs j'ai vu schnyder
bat ça a été assez bonne
chômage 9,1 superbook ainsi en allemagne
il fallut dix ans alors je n'ai pas lu
il est anglais mais bon j'ai pas le
temps de tout lire mais j'aurais bien
aimé moi je me reconnais beaucoup dans
dans ce que dit natacha polony
qui d'autre mais jetez un oeil à ceignac
fedorova je peux nous tentons verde pour
être honnête
voilà vous avez du spoutnik nos noms et
duré 6 minutes 30 ah c'est vrai mais au
bout de 6 minutes 30 qui connaissait pas
la charte de munich dont bon avant
c'était tendu on arrive à la fin de
notre interview on aurait pu continuer
sa encore des heures et des heures mais
vous refais oublie je rate ainsi de
suite ce matin on l'a dépassée le
couvre-feu ouais on dira qu'on était
avec nous et envers à sion mais ils vont
me coucherai ou pas est-ce que vous avez
trois bouquets un conseiller à notre
communauté ouais
un moyen bouquin je suis en train de
dire je n'ai pas totalement finie quel
bouquin ou son admirable de cynthia
fleury sur leurs sentiments je pense à
piège politique un piège individuel
d'abord est un piège politique qui se
finissent par se nourrir lui-même
et je trouve qu'on doit lire en bas les
françaises mais qu'on qui s'appelle sigi
la mer titre un peu compliqué formidable
j'écrivais j
g é
accent circonflexe des c'est ça
le bouquin qui s'appelle les deux clans
très mauvaise traduction en français
de david good heart qui en anglais
s'appelle the road to somewhere
la route vers quelque part et qui est
sûr ce qui est ce conflit au coeur des
sociétés notamment occidentales et
notamment du conflit entre les
populistes
les partisans de la mondialisation
et donc il parle des gens qui sont les
soeurs ware ceux qui sont quelque part
et les any where qui sont de nulle part
où partout
et
moi ça me semble un enjeu fondamental
aujourd'hui pour nos démocraties que de
rassembler j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs le
bouquin alors ça en fera quatre comme ça
de iasi a donc le peuple contre la
démocratie
qui parle
des démocraties libérales et du
libéralisme antidémocratique
et de la raison des crises démocratique
et puis un dernier dans un genre
totalement différent d'une hauteur
bélarus
seul et anna alexievitch
la fin de l'homme rouge
sur l'homme soviétique
sur la la tragédie
les épisodes successifs
d'horreur vécues par les russes
et ce sentiment de trahison
de gens qui ont une forme de fierté
dans l'horreur du stalinisme
mais qui au moment du basculement
d'eltsine voient que leur dignité et
d'acheter et que c'est l'argent qui se
met à demander tout ce bouquin
littéraire enfin cette analyse ceviche
une jambe c'est une journaliste à
l'origine
est devenu écrivain qui écrit et donc
c'est des récits dans tous les sens
c'est très déstructuré
mais où elle donne une force honnêtement
moi je prie bouquin là et
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas c'est
elle aussi qui a écrit la supplication
sur tchernobyl
la guerre à un visage de femme j'ai
appris qu'elle allait bientôt sorte je
crois qu'elle va bientôt sortir un
nouveau bouquin j'ai une très grande
question internet pour qui vous allez
voter pour qui en 2022 ça faisait pas
gérer pas mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que vous avez voté
vaincrons deuxième tour mais je vous
dirai pas et bah quand même et je trouve
que m voyez j'ai dirigé pendant quatre
ans et demi le cfj centre de formation
des journalistes et les élèves y en
avait qui pensaient que j'étais là là
certains qui pensaient que j'étais très
à droite d'autres très à gauche d'autres
très centriste d'autres très écolo donc
très tout et je pense que voilà je pense
qu'on a droit enfin et je m'attache à aa
pas entretenir le mystère pour le
mystère
mais à faire en sorte que que ça ne
porte pas atteinte à l'exercice
professionnel et
l'autre question peut être est ce qu'on
est prêt à défendre des journaux
très partout oui et c'est ce qu'on fait
c'est parce que vous êtes la set-list
vous a reconnu je n'ai pas cité genre là
ça lui passe le bonjour d'ailleurs on
arrive à notre dernière question qui
n'est pas une question qui est laissé un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
quelque chose d'impensable une bouteille
à la mer sur les réseaux
de journalistes ou plus généralement
conseil pour les jeunes générations
je pense que alors je sais les jeunes
générations en france sur internet les
journalistes ne doivent pas dire d'où
ils parlent
ben moi je pense qu'il doit
c'est pas insensé comme question et
c'est une thèse qu'il défend beaucoup je
crois aussi que
moi ce que j'ai toujours tenté de faire
c'est plutôt de m'affranchir de mes
propres de faire un exercice consistant
à de me détacher de ce que je pense moi
dans l'exercice journalistique et si
vous faites ça vous pouvez pas en même
temps mais je comprends qu'on dit ça et
c'est pas
ma réponse et les papes celui là dessus
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
on est le pays où
douze pour cent des gens pensent que le
futur sera mieux qu'aujourd'hui
on est un des pays les plus pessimistes
la planète réaliste
oui enfin en tout cas je dis pas que ce
pessimisme n'est pas réaliste
mais en tout cas on est l'un des pays
les plus pessimistes on n'a plus le sens
de de l'avenir de documents et en fait
ça nous
[Musique]
ça participe de notre dépression aussi
et donc moi
c'est peut-être très banales mais je
pense qu'on a besoin de jeunes
générations pour pour précisément nous
redonner
l'énergie
[Musique]
la gnac l'idéal l'envi de
d'un futur souhaitable christophe
deloire merci merci
[Musique]
dans
e